HD492(CC1) #1695
[ MUSIC ]
>> WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY!
WELCOME TO YOUR WORLDWIDE
GAMEPLAY PREMIERE OF LOGICAL 3.
I'M ONE OF YOUR HOST!
ALONG WITH ANDREA!
>> AND GREG, WHAT'S UP.
>> AND GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD TO YOU, SIR.
WHAT IS EVERYBODY'S HYPE LEVEL
WE ARE HERE?
YOU A, HOW CAN YOU NOT BE HYPED?
WE ARE FINALLY GOING TO SEE
GAMEPLAY.
MAX LEVEL HYPE.
RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE MILLING
ABOUT HERE.
THE ENERGY IS REALLY ELECTRIC.
>> YEAH.
>> AFTER THAT AMAZING REVEAL AT
PAX EAST, FINALLY, WONDERING
WHEN THEY WOULD ANNOUNCE
BORDERLAND 3.
>> THE WAIT IS ALMOST OVER.
YOU HAVE TO PUT UP WITH US FOR
30 MINUTES.
RANDY PITCHFORD AND PAUL SAGE
WILL GIVE ONE HOUR PRESENTATION
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT BORDERLANDS 3.
IF THAT ISN'T ENOUGH, YOU PUT UP
WITH US FOR 30 MINUTES AND THEN,
THREE HOURS OF BORDERLANDS
STREAMERS SHOWING YOU EVERYTHING
YOU CAN DO IN THE GAME.
ANDREA, YOU AND I BORDERLANDS 3!
>> WE HAVE A GOOD LOOK.
OBVIOUSLY THAT TRAILER THEY
DEBUTED A MONTH AND A HALF AGO
HAS BEEN BROKEN DOWN, FRAME BY
FRAME.
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE THESE NEW
VILLAINS.
>> YES.
>> EXACTLY, RIGHT?
TWO NEW VILLAIN, CALYPSO TWINS,
HALT HUNTERS.
SEE GAMEPLAY.
MAYBE FAMILIAR FACES.
>> OF COURSE, BORDERLANDS IS
SUCH A RICH STORY UNIVERSE.
I WANT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT IT.
FRAN.
WHY IS FRAN HERE?
EVERYBODY IS ASKING.
THE SHOOTER GUY.
WHEN ON THE GAME'S CAST, THAT IS
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN STREAMING, THAT IS WHAT YOU
ARE STREAMING.
BORDERLANDS IS NEW TO YOU.
>> I ALWAYS WANTED TO PLAY.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT
THERE.
I'M INTO LOOTER SHOOTERS.
ALL OF THE TIME, WHY HAVEN'T YOU
PLAYED?
I ALWAYS WANTED TO.
WHEN WAS THE RIGHT TIME?
GAME OF THE YEAR TRADITION OUT.
I ALREADY IN.
GOT INTO BORDERLANDS 2.
I DEFINITELY, AM GETTING THE
HOOKS IN ME.
I CAN SEE WHAT MAKES BORDERLANDS
SPECIAL.
I AM EXCITED TO SEE WHAT
BORDERLANDS 3 HAS IN STORE.
HOW IT IS EVOLVING.
>> FOR EVERYBODY.
FANS LIKE ANDREA AND AND PEOPLE
LIKE FRAN WHO FELL OFF THE
TURNIP TRUCK.
>> YES!
[LAUGHTER]
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, NO
MATTER HOW MUCH YOU LOVE OR HATE
BORDERLANDS, YOU HAVE THINGS TO
DO.
SIGN UP FOR THE VAULT INSIDER
PROGRAMS.
SIGN UP, WHAT IT DOES, REWARDS
YOU WITH LOYALTY POINTS TO START
EARNING REWARDS IN BORDERLANDS 3
RIGHT NOW JUST BY GOING THERE,
SYNCING TWITCH ACCOUNT.
BORDERLANDS.COM HAS ALL OF THE
INFORMATION FOR YOU.
>> BUT BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS,
LET'S AGAIN, WE TALK ABOUT THE
PAX TRAILER.
LET'S LOOK AT IT.
LET'S SEE WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
BORDERLANDS 3 SO FAR.
[ MUSIC ]
>> SO THAT IS BORDERLANDS 3.
THOSE ARE THE MEMORIES THAT WE
WILL BE MAKING.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHERE WE
HAVE ALL BEEN WITH BORDERLANDS.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU, NEWB.
FOR YOU, WHAT IS BORDERLANDS
FEATURE YOU HAVE BEEN PLAYING
YOU THINK OF?
YOU THINK BORDERLANDS?
>> YEAH, I HAVE BEEN AROUND IT
FOR SO LONG, THAT PEOPLE IN MY
CAREER HAVE ALWAYS SAID, PLAY
BORDERLANDS.
>> YOU DON'T LISTEN TO US.
BEST FRIEND TELLING YOU TO PLAY.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO SELL ME ON
IT ANYMORE.
I'M IN.
BUT I KNOW WHAT A LOOTER SHOOTER
IS.
I THOUGHT I KNEW WHAT TO EXPECT.
THERE IS SOMETHING SPECIAL ABOUT
2.
THE WAY THAT THEY DO THE LOOT
GRIND.
AND YOU HEAR ABOUT SO MANY GUNS.
WHEN I STARTED PLAYING, IT WAS
GETTING THE WORSE OF THE GUNS.
>> CRAPPY GUN AFTER CRAPPY GUN.
>> I LOVE IT.
HOW IT SCALES.
YOU WAIT, EVERY DROP IS
IMPORTANT SO FAR IN MY
EXPERIENCE.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE HOW THEY
EVOLVE THAT IN 3 IN GETTING
SUPER POWERFUL AND CRAZIER GUNS
HOPEFULLY.
>> AND ANDREA, YOU SAY, WHEN YOU
KILL SOMEONE OR SOMETHING, IT
RAINS GUNS AND SO MUCH LOOT ON
THE GROUND, THAT IS WHAT MAKES
BORDERLANDS SO EXCITE, RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THAT IT IS NOT JUST THE
FACT THAT THERE IS A LOT OF GUNS
OR JUST THE FACT THAT IT IS SO
COOL THAT WAY IT CONFETTIS OUT
OF IT, BUT THE GUNS HAVE SUCH A
UNIQUE PERSONALITY IN THE
BORDERLAND FRANCHISE WHICH
RESONATES WITH FANS.
WHETHER YOU ARE PLAYING WITH A
MOLLIE 1, MENTAL GUNS.
>> I KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS NOW.
YOU ARE GETTING TOO FANCY.
JUST STICK WITH IT.
>> HYPE PERIOD.
>> THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN
SHOOTING SOMEONE AND IT SAY,
RESIST, RESIST.
THAT IS WHY I NEED THE BULLETS.
>> YOU NEED TO BE BETTER WITH
YOUR STRETCH.
>> I HAVE A STRETCH.
SHOOT IT IN THE HEAD UNTIL IT IS
DEAD.
ANDREA, WHAT IS YOUR BORDERLANDS
FEATURE?
>> IN ADDITION TO THE GUN, IT IS
JUST AMAZING CAST OF VAULT
HUNTERS.
WE HAVE SO MANY CHARACTERS OVER
SEVERAL GAMES NOW.
A DOZEN DIFFERENT VAULT HUNTERS
TO CHOOSE FROM.
A WHOLE NEW CROP FROM
BORDERLANDS 3.
THE CHARACTERS IN THE WORLD,
FEEL SO MUCH MORE PERSONALITY
THAN TYPICAL SHOOTER.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
YES.
>> SO MUCH STYLE.
>> WHO DO YOU CHOOSE, WHEN YOU
THINK OF VAULT HUNTER, WHO DO
YOU DEFAULT TO?
WHO DO YOU PLAY?
>> MAYA IS PROBABLY MY FAVORITE.
I LIKE LILITH.
YOU WOULD THINK MY MAIN, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY RED HAIR.
I LOVE CHARACTERS WITH RED HAIR.
SHE IS GREAT.
BUT I LOVE THE SKILL SET THAT
MAYA HAS.
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
SOME MORE GAMEPLAY FROM AMARAH,
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY GAMEPLAY
FROM AM ARIA YET.
SHE IS THE NEW ONE, SHE WILL BE
AWESOME.
>> SHE HAS THE MINI ARMS AND
BICEPS.
>> THE TRAILER.
>> IN THE BEST SIX PACK ABS YOU
HAVE SEEN.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
DON'T MAKE ME TAKE MY SHIRT OFF.
>> WE KNOW THAT YOU ARE NOT
AFRAID TO.
>> WHAT DEFINES BORDERLANDS FOR
ME HAS BEEN ALWAYS THE HUMOR.
THAT IS WHY I THINK OF
HANDSOMEJACK.
CLAPTRAP.
BOTH OF THEM.
TWO DARK AND DISTURBING
CHARACTERS IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
CHARACTERS I LOVE SO MUCH.
HANDSOMEJACK, A HORRIBLE DUDE.
VERY FUNNY.
>> LOVE TO HATE HIM.
>> THROUGH THE COLLECTION,
FEELING FOR HIM.
WHERE WE GET THE TALES FROM THE
BORDERLANDS.
I AM LIKE, DON'T ERASE HIM.
WE HAVE TO SAVE HANDSOMEJACK.
CLAPTRAP SITS THERE WITH HIS
SING SONGY VOICE.
>> YOU SAYING HE IS A MONSTER?
>> LITTLE BIT.
THEY HATE CLAPTRAP BUT LOVE HIM.
>> I LOVE HIM.
>> WHAT IS YOUR CLAPTRAP STORY,
FRAN?
>> I STILL HAVE MUCH TO
EXPERIENCE, WHEN I WAS PLAYING
BORDERLANDS 2, GATE SCENE, NO
BIG SOILERS HERE, SHOOT A GATE
DOWN.
>> ONLY PERSON NEW TO
BORDERLANDS 2 THAT IS WATCHING.
>> THERE ARE MANY NEW FANS I'M
SURE.
HE IS STANDING IN FRONT OF THE
GATE, ALL RIGHT, I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU WHEN TO SHOOT IT AND
STAND HERE.
DON'T SHOOT IT YET.
THAT WOULD BE VERY DANGEROUS.
OKAY.
YOU CAN SHOOT IT BUT NOT YET.
THAT IS A TEST.
THAT WAS MY FIRST, LIKE, BIG WAY
INTO HOW MUCH HUMOR AND STYLE
THEY PUT INTO IT.
IT JUST PREVAILS THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE SERIES.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES BORDERLANDS
SPECIAL.
LIKE YOU SAID, NOT JUST THE
GUNS.
BUT THE STYLE.
IT IS THE CHARACTERS.
AND THE WRITING IS JUST
>> FOR ALL OF THE GUNS I'VE
SHOT, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
BORDERLANDS MEMORY, WHAT COMES
UP TALES OF THE BORDERLANDS,
WHEN GORDU IS INTRODUCED TO
LOADERBOT.
ABOUT TO BE DESTROYED, HEY, HOW
ARE YOU?
IS YOUR DAY?
TO BE HONEST, IT'S A MIXED BAG.
I REMEMBER BEING IN HISTORICS.
WATCH IT BACK ON YOUTUBE.
THAT IS MY MEMORY.
OLD ROOMMATE MIKE, WHEN
BORDERLANDS CAME OUT, MOVED HIS
TV IN THE LIVING ROOM, ONE
FRIDAY, ALL THE WAY TO WORK
MONDAY MORNING, SAT THERE AND
PLAYED BORDERLANDS SIDE BY SIDE.
THAT IS WHAT THIS GAME IS ABOUT.
WHAT IS YOUR MEMORY, ANDREA?
>> FOR ME, THE REASON THAT I
WORE MY SHIRT TODAY, IS TINY
TINA.
RIGHT?
SHE IS SUCH AN AMAZING
CHARACTER.
I VIVIDLY REMEMBER WHEN WE GOT
TO MEET HER IN BORDERLANDS 2.
I MEAN, WHEN DO YOU MEET A
MURDEROUS 13-YEAR-OLD INSIDE A
VIDEO GAME?
I JUST REALLY THOUGHT SHE WAS A
FUN CHARACTER THAT WE HADN'T
SEEN BEFORE.
OF COURSE, THE AMAZING ASHLEY
BURKE.
>> THIS GAME STARTED HER CAREER.
YOU ARE WELCOME, EVERYBODY ELSE.
LIKE THIS STRANGE HORIZON, IT IS
BORDERLANDS.
>> IT IS KIND OF WILD TO THINK
HOW FAR BACK THAT WAS.
RIGHT?
>> RIGHT?
>> HOW MUCH SHE HAS DONE.
>> THE GIRL FROM YOUTUBE.
WHAT YOU ARE PLAYING, IN THIS
VIDEO GAME.
>> CRUSHED IT.
TINY TINA IS MOST I CONIC
CHARACTERS.
WE SEE TINA OLDER.
AND MAYBE IN THE REVEAL TODAY.
>> A TEASE?
I HOPE SO.
FRAN, I WOULD ASK YOU FOR
YOU'RE NEW MEMORY, BUT YOU ARE
NEW ONE.
ONE OF THE BIG CHANGE INTERESTS
BORDERLANDS 1, 2 AND EVEN IN THE
PRE-SEQUEL, THE STREAM SOMETHING
TAKING OFF.
A WHOLE TEAM OF BORDERLANDS
STREAMERS.
THEY WANTED TO SHARE SOME OF
THEIR FAVORITE MOMENTS.
>> TRY TO STEAL MY XP.
TRY TO STEAL IT.
>> OH!
OH!
YOU DIDN'T LIKE THAT!
>> NO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY GOD.
I LOVE YOU!
>> PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BE AROUND
VERY LONG, RIGHT?
NO?
NO YOU ARE DEAD IN TWO SHOTS?
[ MUSIC ]
>> OH, MY GOD!
CLOUD KILL HITS LIKE A TRUCK.
WHAT THE!
WHAT THE [ EXPLETIVE ] IS THAT?
WHAT IS MY LUCK TODAY?
WHAT?
>> IT IS A TRAP.
>> IT KILLED YOU?
>> NO ONE KILLED ME.
>> NO, IT WAS NOT AMAZING.
OH, WE GOT IT.
OH, MY GOSH.
I'M SHAKING.
WE GOT IT.
WE GOT THIS.
THIS NIGHTMARE OF A SNIPER.
OH, MY GOD.
>> WHY DO YOU NEED IT?
BECAUSE IT IS AWESOME.
LOOK AT IT BLOW STUFF UP.
>> THE PLAN DIDN'T WORK.
>> YEAH!
>> I KILLED HIM BY JUMPING ON
HIM!
DEATH BY JUMP.
>> TRYING TO SELL ALL OF THIS
STUFF.
>> I HATE THIS.
I'M DONE.
I'M LEAVING.
>> MAN!
THAT WAS AWESOME!
>> THAT IS WHAT BORDERLANDS IS
ALL ABOUT.
GETTING THE BIG LOOT DROP AND
SCREAMING, RUNNING, DYING A LOT.
THEY DIED A LOT IN THAT.
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF DYING.
>> I THINK THAT BORDERLANDS IS
SO GREAT MAKING YOU FEEL
EMPOWERED AND SEE EVERYONE
SCREAMING AND CRUSHED BY ROCKS
AND THINGS FLIPPING OVER.
>> NEVER KNOW WHAT YOU WILL GET.
THAT IS WHAT IS SPECIAL ABOUT-I.
>> OF COURSE.
IF YOU NEED MORE BORDERLANDS
STREAMING IN YOUR LIFE, OF
COURSE, THEY ARE STREAMING
MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY FEATURING
MANY OF THE STREAMERS YOU JUST
SAW.
AND, ALSO, HUGE BOSSES.
WE KNOW ABOUT LOOT.
WE KNOW ABOUT CHARACTERS.
ABOUT COMEDY.
BORDERLANDS IS KNOWN FOR PUTTING
IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT BOSSES.
THOSE SAME STREAMERS PUT
TOGETHER ANOTHER VIDEO PACKAGE
FOR YOU SHOWCASING SOME OF THEIR
FAVORITE BOSS BYTES AND LOOT
DROPS.
>> DO YOU LIKE LOOTING?
DO YOU LIKE SHOOTING?
YOU'LL LIKE BORDERLANDS.
>> LOOK AT THAT DAMAGE.
LOOK AT THAT DAMAGE, GUYS.
>> OH, YEAH!
>> YES!
>> YEAH!
>> OH, THAT WAS AWESOME.
>> OH, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WHAT AM I DOING RIGHT?
OH, MY GOD, I LIVED.
>> OKAY.
THAT IS BAD.
>> WHAT ARE THE ACTUAL, WHAT IS
GOING ON?
[ SCREAMING ]
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT IS TOO MUCH, DUDE.
WHAT IF I GET REAL CLOSE?
>> WHOOPS!
BAD PLAN.
>> KILL IT!
I'M SO GOOD!
>> YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
>> FROM MERCY!
>> WAIT.
WAIT.
>> GOT HIM!
>> COME ON, DIE.
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE.
>> YES!
I DID IT.
YES!
>> YOU'RE STUPID FACE.
>> I TOLD YOU, BOSSES WILL NOT
BE FUN TODAY.
OH, MY GOD!
>> WOW!
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME GUYS?
YES, YES, YES!
YES!
OH, MY GOD!
I'M CRYING.
I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS EVER GOING
TO HAPPEN.
TODAY WAS MY LUCKY DAY.
>> OH, WHAT MEMORIES THAT
MONTAGE BRINGS BACK, ANDREA.
DO YOU REMEMBER DOING THAT?
RUNNING GRINDS, TRYING TO GET
THE RIGHT GUN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
REPLAYING MISSIONS WITH MY
FRIENDS.
>> YES.
>> BECAUSE I NEVER WANTED TO
WAIT FOR THEM TO GET ON-LINE AND
PLAY.
I WOULD HAVE TO JUMP INTO THEIR
GAME.
RUN THE SAME MISSIONS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
BUT LIKE, IT IS LIKE YOU NEVER
KNOW WHEN YOU WILL GET THAT
MAGICAL, LEGENDARY DROP.
>> I REMEMBER AGAIN, BACK WITH
PLAYING WITH MIKE.
SO OBSESSED.
RUN THE SAME BOSS BYTE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
TRYING TO GET THE RIGHT DROP.
RUN 36.
FRAN, WHAT IS SO HYPNOTIC ABOUT
LOOTER SHOOTERS THAT PEOPLE,
THAT WILL HAPPEN FOR THEM?
SIT THERE AND DO IT OVER AND
OVER?
>> YOU ARE DESCRIBING WHY THON
OF MY FRIENDS EVER SEE ME
OUTSIDE OF THE HOUSE.
THAT IS WHAT GETS ME, THAT
PERFECT DROP.
THE DROP THAT YOUR FRIENDS ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT MAKES
LOOTER SHOOTERS SPECIAL.
IT IS THAT YOU ARE NOT
GUARANTEED TO GET IT.
AND ONE, IT IS HOW FUN IS THE
CHALLENGE OF FACING THE BOSS.
PLAYING WITH YOUR FRIEND, OF
COURSE.
BUT IT IS LIKE, I ALWAYS EQUATE
IT TO MAYBE IN THE GAME ITSELF,
YOU GO TO MOXXIES, PULL THE
LEVEL, PLAYING THE SLOT, YOU
MIGHT GET THE DROP BUT MIGHT GET
A GRENADE AND POPS OUT.
YOU GET DAMAGE.
WHEN YOU GET SOMETHING SPECIAL,
MAN, IT IS SO MEANINGFUL AND
ADDS TO THE POWER.
THAT IS, I JUST CAN'T WAIT TO
PLAY MORE OF BORDERLANDS 2 NOW.
GO BACK TO IT.
I HAVEN'T FINISHED IT YET.
>> GET OFF THE STAGE!
SECURITY!
>> GOSH!
YOU STARTLED ME.
>> I'M SORRY.
I'M HERE TOO.
>> YOU THINK I WOULD BE USED TO
IT.
>> YOU THINK THEY HIRED ME FOR
THIS STREAM, I WOULD BE QUIET.
I CAN'T.
SPEAKING OF NOT BEING QUIET,
GREG, DO YOU HAVE AWESOME
BORDERLANDS CLIPS THAT YOU WOULD
LOVE TO SHARE WITH THE GEARBOX
TEAM?
GET ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
#BORDERLANDS 3.
YOU MIGHT BE FEATURED IN
BORDERLANDS 3 EVENTS.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS IT FAR FROM
LAST STOP, I'M SURE.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT TRADE SHOWS
COMING UP.
THIS THING IN LA SOON.
>> I THOUGHT A COPY UNDER THE
SEAT.
TAKING ONE HOME.
>> NO, NO.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THEY WERE
LIKE, GUESS WHAT?
WE LIED.
IT IS OUT NOW.
>> OH!
>> IF RANDY IS LISTENING, GOOD
IDEA.
>> HE HAS THE POWER.
>> RIGHT.
AGAIN, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE
ARE TALKING TODAY ABOUT
BORDERLANDS 3, I SWEAR.
IN THE CHAT, YOU ARE LIKE, SHOW
US BORDERLANDS 3.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU
BORDERLANDS 3.
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO WHERE WE
ARE GOING, WE NEED TO CATCH YOU
UP ON THE STORY SO FAR.
SO HERE IS EVERYTHING YOU NEED
TO KNOW ABOUT THE BORDERLANDS
UNIVERSE SO FAR.
>> OH, PANDORA!
A SAVAGE DESOLATE WASTELAND OF A
CLIMATE.
THAT IS UNTIL ITS LEGENDARY
VAULT WAS FORCED OPEN.
AND THE PRICELESS ALIEN MINERAL
GREW ACROSS THE WORLD.
ENTER THE GREEDY TYRANT.
CEO, HANDSOMEJACK.
WITH A FORTUNE MADE FROM
HARVESTING THIS, HE SET HIS
SIGHTS ON A NEW VAULT.
THE VAULT OF THE WARRIOR.
RUMORS OF THIS NEW VAULT LURED
THE BAND OF BRAVE FOOLS, THE NEW
VAULT HUNTERS SEEKING THEIR
FORTUNES.
JACK WAS SET ON ELIMINATING ALL
COMPETITION AND TRIED TO HAVE
THEM KILLED BUT THEY SURVIVED.
AND JOIN THE CRIMSON RAIDERS IN
THEIR CRUSADE AGAINST THEM.
WITH THE GUARDIAN ANG YEAL ON
THEIR SIDE, THEY SEEM WELL ON
THEIR WAY TO GLORY.
BUT THE ANGEL WAS NOT ALL SHE
APPEARED TO BE.
SHE DOUBLE CROSSED THE VAULT
HUNTERS.
TRICKED THEM INTO SABOTAGING THE
CRIMSON RAIDERS.
AND GAVE JACK THE UPPERHAND.
REALIZING SHE WAS BEING USED AS
HIS PAWN, SHE TURNED ON HANDSOME
JACK.
THE VAULT HUNTERS LEARNED THAT
ANGEL WAS NO MACHINE AS THEY HAD
BELIEVED.
BUT ONE OF THE SIX SIRENS AND
IMPRISONED BY HER FATHER, JACK.
HE INJECTED HER WITH IT, TO
CHARGE THE VAULT KING, IN THE
VALIANT EFFORT TO STOP JACK'S
PLAN SHE SACRIFICED HERSELF.
ENRAGED BY THE DEATH OF HIS
DAUGHTER AND DETERMINED NOT TO
FAIL, JACK CAPTURED ANOTHER
SIREN, LILITH.
AND FORCED HER TO CHARGE THE
VAULT KEY AND AWAKEN THE
WARRIOR.
FOR YOU SEE, THIS VAULT WAS NO
TREASURE CHAMBER BUT THE RESTING
PLACE FOR AN ANCIENT MERIDIAN
CONSTRUCT, AN ALIEN COLOSSO,
CONTROLLED WITH WHOEVER WOKE IT
WITH THE POWER OF THE KEY.
KILL!
>> SO FINALLY, LET'S TURN OUR
EYES TO BORDERLANDS 3, WILD
SPECULATION TIME.
ANDREA, WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING
FROM BORDERLANDS 3 TODAY?
>> I'M CERTAINLY EXPECTING A LOT
MORE LOCATIONS THAN WE SAW IN
PREVIOUS BORDERLANDSS FROM THE
TRAILER THAT WE SEEN SO FAR.
THEY DID A LOT OF FAST CUTS OF
SOME REALLY COOL LOOKING SPOTS
THAT DON'T LOOK LIKE PANDORA.
I'M HOPING TO GET A REVEAL THAT
THEY ARE REALLY EXPANDING.
>> OTHER WORLDS.
>> THE BORDERLANDS UNIVERSE
TODAY.
>> SURE, WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM
THE STORY, YOU THINK?
>> FROM THE STORY?
OBVIOUSLY, I WANT TO KNOW WHO
THE TWINS ARE.
AND WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH
MOTIVATIONS.
>> HOW DARE THEY.
WHERE DID YOU COME FROM, TWINS?
>> THEY HAVE A REALLY COOL STYLE
TO THEM.
THEY --
>> AS MOST THINGS IN THE
BORDERLANDS UNIVERSE.
>> OBVIOUSLY.
THEY LOOK A LOT YOUNGER,
OBVIOUSLY, THAN HANDSOME JACK
WAS.
>> GREAT HAIR LIKE HANDSOME
JACK.
GREAT HAIR.
>> EVERYONE IN BORDERLANDS HAS
>> THAT IS WHY FRANK FIT RIGHT
IN.
THE WORLD OF PANDORA.
>> BORDERLANDS, GET ME IN THERE.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT STORY WISE?
>> I HAVE THIS DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AS WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN I PLAYED FROM BORDERLANDS 1
TO 2, I SAW THIS HUGE QUALITY OF
LIFE IMPROVEMENT.
THE WORLD DESIGN.
THE LOOT.
THE PACE OF THINGS.
MORE VIBRANT.
I'M EXPECTING TO SEE, YOU KNOW,
EVEN A BIGGER GAP BETWEEN TWO
AND THREE COMING.
SO A LOT OF THE QUALITY AND LIFE
STUFF.
THE BIGGER WORLD, MORE
PRODUCTION VALUE.
>> SURE.
>> ALL OF THE ABOVE.
IT IS 2019.
IT HAS BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE WE
SEEN BORDERLANDS.
I HOPE TO SEE A BIG LEAP.
>> YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
FOR ME RIGHT.
STORYLINE WISE, LIKE BORDERLANDS
1 AND 2.
FUNNY, GREAT, A REASON TO SHOOT
A LOT OF THINGS.
BUT IT IS 2019.
THAT IS WHAT GETS ME EXCITED FOR
GAMEPLAY.
I LOVED BORDERLANDS 1, 2,
PRE-SEQUEL, TALES.
THAT A DIFFERENT GAMEPLAY.
WHAT DOES A MODERN BORDERLANDS
LOOK LIKE?
>> EVERYTHING, THE DRIVE, THE
JUMPING.
THE AIMING.
EVERY GAME MAKES THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS.
AND I THINK THAT MAYBE WE TAKE
FOR GRANTED HOW LONG IT HAS
BEEN.
I'M HOPING TO SEE BIG CHANGES
THERE.
ALTHOUGH IT IS ALREADY GREAT.
>> THAT IS THE THING I WANT TO
TOUCH ON, I DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY
DON'T NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL
HERE.
WHEN RANDY ON STAGE AT PAX EAST,
HE MADE THE BIG JOKE ABOUT
BATTLE ROYAL.
THERE WERE PEOPLE THINKING THAT
BORDERLANDS WAS GOING THAT
ROUTE, SINCE A POPULAR GENRE
RIGHT NOW.
NO, THAT IS COOL BUT WE ARE NOT
MAKING THAT GAME.
SO I DON'T REALLY WANT THEM TO
DEVIATE.
>> OH, NO.
>> THAT IS FAIR.
>> BORDERLANDS IS GREAT THE WAY
IT IS.
>> IF IT AIN'T BROKE, DON'T FIX
IT.
GOING BACK TO PLAY WITH YOU,
FRAN, WHEN PLAYING GAME OF THE
YEAR BORDERLANDS 1, IT WAS VERY
MUCH LIKE, OH, MAN, I LOVE
BORDERLANDS.
JUMPING IN THERE, OH, HOW DO I,
MENUUE?
IT HAS BEEN A WHILE.
THIS IS AN OLD GAME.
>> IT WAS AMAZING.
>> YEAH, YEAH, TOTALLY.
NOW TO GET WHAT MAKES
BORDERLANDS IN 2019, LIKE, I AM
EXCITED FOR THAT.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THAT.
AND LIKE, EVEN LIKE, THE LITTLE
CHANGE WE SAW IN THE TRAILER, WE
WATCHED, RUNNING GUNS.
>> YEAH.
>> THE ABILITY OF --
>> WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN?
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO EXPAND
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE FRANCHISE
WORLD?
>> YEAH, A HALF DECADE IN THE
THINK TANK.
I THINK, WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH
THE GUNS THAT ARE GETTING
CRAZIER?
I DIDN'T EXPECT TO SEE LEGS ON
GUNS.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT ELSE
THEY DONE WITH THEM.
>> WHAT ELSE IS GREAT TO SEE
TODAY, HOW THEY WILL HANDLE THE
LOOT SCENES.
PUBLICLY ANNOUNCE, YOU WILL GET
YOUR OWN LOOT STREAM.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, RIGHT?
>> THAT IS ONGOING ISSUE WITH
CO-OP GAMES THAT HAVE A LOOT
GAME.
DEVELOPERS HAVE HANDLED IT
DIFFERENTLY.
>> I FEEL THEY NAILED IT.
STILL ALWAYS A PART IN ANY END
GAME, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU ARE PLAYING SOMETHING
LIKE THE DIVISION 2, LIKE FRAN
AND I DO.
YOU GET THERE, IT IS GREAT BUT
GOING BACK AND TRYING TO PLAY
WITH A LOW LEVEL PERSON, IT IS,
ALL RIGHT.
I KILLED EVERYTHING FOR YOU.
HOW DO YOU FIGURE THAT OUT?
IN BORDERLANDS, IT HAS BEEN SO
CLUTCH AT MAKING WHAT
BORDERLANDS IS AND WHAT
BORDERLANDS IS.
AND MAKING THESE GAMES BE TRUE
AUTHENTIC TO WHAT THE
BORDERLANDS FRANCHISE IS.
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE IN 2019
IN.
>> I'M WITH ANDREA.
AS MUCH AS I'M NEW TO IT, I
DON'T WANT TO SEE A BUNCH OF BIG
CHANGES.
BORDERLANDS IS SPECIAL FOR THOSE
REASONS.
DO WE NEED A BIG RAID?
DO WE NEED END GAME?
WELL, YOU ALWAYS NEED AN END
GAME BUT, THESE CLASSIC LOOTER
SHOOTERS I PLAY, YEAH, I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE NEED ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT THINGS.
THE HYPE IS, PEOPLE ARE READY.
>> THE PEOPLE ARE READY.
>> THE ENERGY IS GROWING.
>> YEAH.
>> IF THE ENERGY IS GROWING AT
YOUR HOUSE, JUST PERFECT TIME TO
REMIND YOU ABOUT THE TWITCH
EXTENSION ECHO PASS, IF YOU GO
TO BORDERLANDS.COM RIGHT NOW,
YOU CAN SIGN UP.
YOU CAN START EARNING
BORDERLANDS' REWARDS FOR
WATCHING THIS.
IT WILL COME INTO PLAY,
IMPORTANTLY IN THE POST-STREAM.
I'LL TELL YOU ABOUT IT LATER.
LOOK NOW.
IT IS A TWITCH EXTENSION THAT
LETS YOU WATCH PLAYERS PLAY THE
GAME AND GO INTO LOOT OUTS AND
CHECK OUT GUNS.
COOL THINGS TO BE ABLE TO DO AS
WELL, AS WELL AS GETTING YOUR
OWN STUFF IN BORDERLANDS.
>> NUMBER ONE, JUDGE THE
STREAMERS LOOT.
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED.
>> JUDGMENT.
>> YOU SHOULD CHANGE YOUR SKILL
TREE UP, THIS IS A BETTER WAY.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
THE CHAT WHY YOU ARE DOING
SOMETHING.
THEY CAN SEE IT THEMSELVES.
AND YOU SUCK.
>> YOU CAN EARN LOOT BY WATCH
AUGUST THAT IS A GREAT WAY TO
INTERACT WITH THE STREAMER YOU
ALREADY ARE WATCHING AND REMIND
PEOPLE TO STAY ENGAGED IN THAT
STREAM.
>> THAT IS, I MEAN, THAT SPEAKS
TO WHAT I AM TALKING ABOUT.
RIGHT?
THAT IS THE KIND OF
INTERACTTIVITY AND THINKING
OUTSIDE THE BOX I EXPECT FROM
BORDERLANDS.
YOU SEE THEM TOUCHING ON WHAT
GAMING IS RIGHT NOW IN OUR DAY
AND AGE.
RIGHT?
TO USE TWITCH IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
HOW TO USE IT IN A WAY THAT NOT
ONLY MAKES IT BETTER FOR THE
VIEWER BUT THE PLAYER.
FRAN, YOU TWITCH STREAM ALL OF
THE TIME.
ON TWITCH.TVFM.
AND YOU HAVE THE SAME QUESTION
OVER AND OVER.
WHEN PEOPLE POP IN, ASKING YOU,
WHAT ARE YOU ROLLING?
WHY DOING THIS?
NOW CAN JUST LOOK AT IT ON THEIR
OWN.
>> THAT IS NUMBER ONE.
2019, I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT
IT, CLEARLY IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR THEM HERE.
IT IS EARLY, THEY HAVE TIME TO
GO.
THEY COME UP NOW, I WONDER IF WE
WILL SEE MORE TO THE EXTENSION
OF HOW YOU EXPAND ON JUST CO-OP
IN THE COMMUNITY.
>> YEAH.
>> PEOPLE WATCHING.
THAT COULD BE A HOOK.
>> EARN LOOT.
THAT IS SO COOL.
EVERYBODY WANTS MORE OF THAT.
>> MAYBE MESS WITH THE LOOT.
MAYBE A WAY TO PUT YOU IN THE
GAME.
>> I HOPE NOT.
I THINK THAT MAYBE JUST GOING A
LITTLE TOO FAR.
>> SORRY, YOU BLEW UP.
>> SPEAKING OF GOING TOO FAR,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE WILL
NOT GO TOO FAR.
YOU HAVE BEEN VERY PATIENT.
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING UP WITH
US.
IT IS TIME FOR YOU TO SEE AN
HOUR LONG PRESENTATION OF
BORDERLANDS 3 PRESENTED OF
COURSE, BY PAUL SAGE, RANDY
PITCHFORD.
THEN OF COURSE, STICK AROUND FOR
A POST SHOW WITH US.
THEN THREE HOURS OF YOUR
FAVORITE BORDERLANDS STREAMERS
PLAYING THE GAME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THIS IS
BORDERLANDS 3.
[ MUSIC ]
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE!
APPOMATTOX WELCOME TO THE
BORDERLANDS 3 GAMEPLAY REVEAL
EVENT.
PLEASE WELCOME TO THE STAGE
BORDERLANDS 3 CREATIVE DIRECTOR
PAUL SAGE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] PLEASE
WELCOME TO THE STAGE, GEARBOX
SOFTWARE FOUNDER, ME!
RANDY PITCHFORD.
HOW IS IT GOING, GUYS?
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE IN
HOLLYWOOD, CALIFORNIA.
AS WE SHARE BORDERLANDS 3
GAMEPLAY FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT TEN
YEARS AGO, BORDERLANDS USHERED
IN THE SHOOTER LOOTER.
I MEAN, WHO WE ARE.
WE ARE ABOUT HERE TO EXPERIENCE
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT HAS BEEN ABOUT FIVE YEARS
SINCE THE GEARBOX SOFTWARE
DEVELOPER TEAM STARTED WORKING
ON THIS GAME.
WE ARE SO EXCITED TO BE HERE TO
SHARE IT WITH YOU TODAY.
>> NOW I KNOW THAT EVERYBODY IS
USED TO HEARING ME AND RANDY
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE TEAM,
TODAY, I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
YOU TO SOME OF THE REST OF THE
TALENT BEHIND BORDERLANDS.
>> THE BORDERLANDS 3 TEAM, YOU
GUYS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
THESE DEVELOPERS ON STAGE
INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WITH FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
WHEN WE CREATED THE SHOOTER
LOOTER GENRE.
GREAT TALENT THAT HAS JOINED
WITH US ALONG THE WAY.
ALL OF US HERE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER WITH OUR PEERS BACK IN
GEARBOX FRISCO HQ AND GEARBOX
STUDIO QUEBEC.
WE ARE THRILLED TO BE HERE TO
FINALLY SHARE OUR WORK.
IF YOU EVER ENJOYED A
BORDERLANDS GAME OR LOOKING
FORWARD TO BORDERLANDS 3, IF YOU
WILL INDULGE ME ONE MORE TIME,
SHOW THIS TEAM, THIS TALENT.
>> THEY WILL JOIN US IN A BIT.
EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY LATER TO GO HANDS-ON
WITH BORDERLANDS 3 AND THIS
TIME, WE WILL BE WITH YOU
HELPING YOU OUT.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
JEREMY, DEQUAN, COULD YOU STAY
BEHIND?
>> THEY WILL BE PLAYING.
RIGHT HERE.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE BEEN TO
AN EVENT LIKE THIS BEFORE.
ALL OF THIS IS MADE POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF OUR PUBLISHING
PARTNER 2K GAMES, AND SUPPORT
FROM HARDWARE PARTNER AMD
POWERED BY RIESSEN AND RADION.
WE HAVE INCREDIBLE [ EXPLETIVE ]
BY THEM.
WE WANTED TO PUT THAT AMD
HARDWARE TO THE TEST WITH A
POWERPOINT.
SO CAN WE START THE
PRESENTATION?
>> YEAH!
SO WE PREPARED A PRESENTATION ON
WHAT THE NEXT BORDERLANDS GAME
WILL BE.
>> YOU ARE LOOKING AT ENGINE
RENDERED IMAGE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF BORDERLANDS 3.
LOOK AT THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT IS PANDORA.
THE ART.
THE STYLE.
THE GOAL WAS TO TRY TO CREATE AN
IMAGE THAT WAS FRESH BUT ALSO
FAMILIAR.
WE WANTED TO LOOK FORWARD AND
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGY IN A WAY THAT
RESPECTS THAT ONE OF A KIND ART
DIRECTION KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE
VIDEO GAME WORLD AS THE
BORDERLANDS ART STYLE.
>> OKAY.
LET'S BE HONEST, THIS ISN'T AN
ACTUAL SCREEN SHOT FROM THE
GAME.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS THE
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] NOW WE
SKIPPED PAST THE LOGOS AND A LOT
OF THE INTRODUCTIONS BECAUSE WE
FELT THAT THE MOST HONEST WAY TO
BRING THE GAME TO YOU TODAY, WAS
TO START FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
SO WITH THAT, LET'S PLAY SOME
BORDERLANDS 3.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YOU MUST BE THE NEW RECRUIT.
I'M A STEWART BOT.
AND YOU CAN CALL ME GENERAL
CLAPTRAP OF THE CRIMSON RAIDERS.
WHAT IS YOUR NAME?
>> AMARA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I'LL PREPARE YOUR TOMBSTONE
JUST IN CASE.
THOSE JERKS THAT TRY TO RUN YOU,
THE CHILDREN OF THE CULT.
ABANDONED CULT THAT FOLLOW THE
CREEPY LEADERS WITH BLIND
DEVOTION WHICH REMINDS ME, IF
YOU ARE GOING TO OBEY MY EVERY
BECKON CALL, YOU WILL NEED AN
ECHO DEVICE.
TRY IT OUT.
I RINSED IT OFF MYSELF.
THE ELKO 3.
SLIGHTLY MORE POWERFUL THAN THE
ECHO 2 AND TWICE AS EXPENSIVE.
BESIDES, THE ECHO 2 HAD A TINY
ISSUE WITH SPONTANEOUS
COMBUSTION.
NOW LISTEN UP, RECRUIT, LILITH
ORDERED US TO TAKE OVER THE
CHILDREN OF THE BULK PROPAGANDA
CENTER.
TRY TO SHOW THOSE KULTI WEIRDOES
THAT NO ONE MESSES WITH THE
CRIMSON RAIDERS.
FOLLOW ME TO GLORY!
>> SO LILITH ORDERED US TO TAKE
OVER THE RECRUITMENT CENTER OF
THE CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
IN THE INTRODUCTION THAT WE
SKIPPED, YOU WOULD LEARN THAT
THE CHILDREN OF THE VAULT IS A
NEW CULT THAT HAS EMERGED ON
PANDORA.
SIREN LILITH AND THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS ARE RECRUITING NEW VAULT
HUNTER, THAT IS YOU, US, AND WE
ARE TO INVESTIGATE THE CHILDREN
OF THE VAULT CULT AND DISCOVER
WHO THEIR MYSTERIOUS LEADERS
ARE.
>> BEFORE WE REEK OUR RIGHTEOUS
VENGEANCE, REGISTER YOUR ECHO AT
THIS CHANGE.
ONCE WE DEFEAT THE CULT, I'LL BE
FAMOUS.
WHEN I AM SIGNING AUTOGRAPHS, I
NEED YOU LOOKING SHARP WHILE
DEFENDING ME FROM MY
FAN/STALKERS.
>> AS HERE, WE ARE PLAYING
AMARA.
A WARRIOR.
AS CLAPTRAP MENTIONED, QUICK
CHANGE, UP TO YOU HOW YOU WANT
YOUR CHARACTER TO LOOK.
YOU CAN CHANGE AMARA AND CHANGE
IT OBVIOUSLY.
LET'S KEEP PLAYING FOR NOW,
GUYS.
>> USER AGREEMENT?
BORING.
DON'T WORRY.
CORPORATIONS HAVE OUR BEST
INTEREST AT HEART.
THE PROPAGANDA CENTER IS THIS
WAY!
LOCK, ENGAGE.
THAT CAN'T BE HAPPENING.
THE ENTIRE MISSION IS RUINED.
THINK CLAPTRAP, YOU ARE GREAT,
POWERFUL AND PEOPLE ALWAYS DO
WHAT YOU TELL THEM TO.
THAT IS IT.
RECRUIT.
GET THAT GATE OPEN.
THIS IS AN ORDER FROM YOUR
SUPERIOR OFFICER.
>> SO OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE GETTING
A GLIMPSE HERE ON HOW WE USE THE
BEGINNING OF THE GAME TO MAKE
SURE THAT PLAYERS ARE UP TO
SPEED HOW FIRST PERSON VIDEO
GAMES WORK.
WE CAN VALIDATE THAT PLAYERS
UNDERSTAND HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND INTERACT WITH
IT.
>> YOU DID IT!
BEST RECRUIT EVER!
DON'T GET COCKY.
>> WE'LL EVEN BE ABLE TO KNOW
HOW A PLAYER HAS LEARNED HOW TO
CROUCH AND HOW TO SLIDE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] YOU HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN JUMP.
AND IF YOU MISS, THAT YOU CAN
MANTLE UP, CLIMB THE HIGHER
LEDGES.
>> THE PROPAGANDA CENTER IS UP
AHEAD.
THEY HAVE BEEN KILLING LEFT AND
RIGHT.
THEY TOTALLY SUCK SKAG BALLS.
I HAVE A FULL PROOF PLAN TO KICK
THEIR [ EXPLETIVE ].
>> WITH MOST GAMES, WE ARE USING
THE BEGIN TO TEACH THE
FUNDAMENTALS AND SETTING THE
TONE OF THE GAME.
RIGHT?
JUST LIKE OUR UNIQUE ART STYLE,
WE WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL RIGHT
AWAY WHAT WE BELIEVE HELPS
BORDERLANDS SPECIAL.
A STYLE OF WRITING THAT IS
RIVERRENCE AND GENUINE.
>> I HID A WEAPONS CASH NEARBY.
STAY QUIET AND FOLLOW MY EVERY
MOVE.
IT IS SEALTH TIME!
[ SINGING ]
PERFECT.
ONCE WE COMPLETE OUR MISSION,
LILITH HAS TO PROMOTE ME TO
SUPER GENERAL.
STAND BACK!
>> SO WE ARE THROWING SETH OUT
THE WINDOW?
>> RELAX, IT IS PANDORA, SUPER
WEIRD IF SOMETHING IS NOT
EXPLODING.
TAKE YOUR GUN, RECRUIT.
YOU WILL NEED IT.
THESE GUNS, LIKE MYSELF, AREN'T
BEHOLDEN TO PRIMARY FUNCTION.
I CAN DANCE.
AND SING.
♪ AND NOW SOME GUNS INCLUDE AN
ALTERNATE SHOOTING MODE  ♪
>> TRY IT OUT!
FOLLOW ME, RECRUIT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IS CLAPTRAP JUST MENTIONED IN
ORDER TO STAY COMPETITIVE, SOME
OF OUR GUN MANUFACTURERS HAVE
ADDED ALTERNATE FIRING MODES.
IF WE LOOK HERE, WE CAN SEE THAT
WE HAVE A PISTOL.
IF WE FIRE REGULARLY, WE FIRE
BULLETS.
BUT IF WE SWITCH OUR ALTERNATE
FIRING MODES, WE FIRE OFF MICRO
MISSILES.
[APPLAUSE] NOW LATER IN THE
GAME, YOU WILL FIND GUNS THAT
CAN SWITCH BETWEEN ICE BULLETS
AND FIRE BULLETS OR YOU MIGHT
FIND GUNS THAT HAVE A CHAIN GUN
ON TOP, WHEN SWITCH FIRING
MODES, SHOOT GRENADES.
IT GETS CRAZY.
PLAYER WHOSE MAXIMIZE ALL FIRE
MODES, TWICE THE NUMBER OF GUNS
AVAILABLE THAN THEY HAD TO START
WITH.
>> WAIT HERE.
I WILL TALK MY WAY IN, BECOME
THEIR KING AND YOU WILL SURPRISE
SLAUGHTER THEM IN COLD BLOOD.
WATCH AND LEARN, RECRUIT.
HELLO!
ANYONE THERE?
>> THE INFLUENCER ON THE
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
WHAT DO YOU WANT BOT?
>> HELLO, BLOOD THIRSTY MANIAC.
IT IS I, CLAPTRAP, SLAYER OF THE
DESTROYER.
SUPER GENERAL OF THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
WE HAVE YOU COMPLETELY
SURROUNDED.
OPEN THE GATES NOW.
PERHAPS I WILL BE MERCIFUL.
>> OH, YEAH, LET ME THINK ABOUT
THAT.
>> THEY MIGHT CALL THEMSELVES
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT BUT STILL
BANDITS.
BANDITS ARE INCREDIBLY STUPID.
>> OKAY.
WE ARE GOING TO SURRENDER.
PLEASE DON'T KILL US.
>> THAT IS WHAT I THOUGHT.
OPEN THE DOORS IMMEDIATELY FOR
YOUR NEW KING.
>> EASY, EASY.
WE ARE COMING OUT.
JUST WAIT RIGHT THERE.
>> HE DID IT.
I DID IT.
ANOTHER VICTORY FOR THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
HEY, I FEEL FUNNY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO ME?
WHOA!
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> SEE THE DEGRADING COVER.
>> LOOKIE WHAT WE GOT HERE!
>> OH, OH!
BORDERLANDS 3 IS RATED M FOR
MATURE, RIGHT?
>> PUT THESE BULLETS INTO THE
BAD GUY, RIGHTED?
>> YOU ARE GOING TO BE MY NEW
TEAM BOT.
I'M GOING TO GET IN YOUR HEAD.
>> WHOA!
REGROUP!
>> I KNOW CLAPTRAP CAN BE A
LITTLE CLAPTRAP BUT HE IS STILL
ONE OF US.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO SAVE
HIM.
I'LL BE THERE SOON.
>> SO LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND
SOME LOOT.
I SAW OVER HERE NEAR THAT DOOR,
I SAW A RED CHEST.
IT LOOKS LIKE A TRUNK OF A CAR.
WHAT DO WE GOT HERE?
WHAT ELSE IS THERE?
OH, THAT IS INTERESTING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WE CAN SEE THAT THIS WEAPON
HAS HIGH ACCURACY, HIGHER
HANDLING, LET'S LOOK AT THE
OTHER ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS WEAPON HAS HIGHER DAMAGE
AND HIGHER RELOAD TIME.
IT IS FINESSE OR BRUTE FORCE IN
THIS CASE.
>> WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
SHOOT FROM THE HIP OR BAD [
EXPLETIVE ] SCOPE?
I THINK THAT YOU GUYS SAID
SCOPE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
TAKE BOTH OF THEM.
WE WILL TRY THE SCOPE AND THEN
WE WILL SWITCH.
THAT IS PRETTY BAD [ EXPLETIVE
].
THESE ARE LIKE LEVEL ONE GUNS,
TOO.
>> OVER HERE!
>> OH!
>> OIL IS FLAMMABLE.
>> THERE IS NO WAY WITH YOUR
DELICATE BODY CAN SURVIVE A
SHOWDOWN.
LOOK AROUND FOR A SHIELD!
>> OKAY.
WE NEED A SHIELD.
THIS IS AN AREA MISSION.
IF WE LOOK AROUND, WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO FIND SOME SOMEWHERE.
NOT IN THE SKAG PILE.
>> DEQUAN, YOU ON THIS?
ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT LOOKS PROMISING.
THERE WE GO.
77.
105, THAT IS BETTER.
TAKE THAT ONE.
>> IT JUST MIGHT KEEP HIM FROM
KILLING YOU IN ONE HIT.
LET'S GET YOU IN THERE RECRUIT.
HEY!
ALL YOUR DUMB FRIENDS ARE DEAD!
I CHALLENGE YOU TO A TRIAL BY
COMBAT!
BUT BECAUSE I'M STUCK WITH THIS,
MY ROYAL SHALL TAKE ISSUE
INSTEAD.
>> COME ON IN.
I HAVEN'T MET MY SACRIFICE QUOTA
FOR THE DAY!
>> SO I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GETTING AHEAD OF ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS COMING NEXT.
THIS IS OUR FIRST MINI BOSS
FIGHT.
DEQUAN, YOU READY?
WE ARE FLYING WITHOUT A NET
HERE.
NO GOD MODE.
SO LET'S DO IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NICE!
>> OH!
[APPLAUSE]
>> MY GOD!
THAT WAS AWESOME.
>> SCORE ONE FOR THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
YOU AND CLAPTRAP SECURE THE
AREA.
I'M ON MY WAY.
>> THIS GAME IS DYNAMIC,
DIFFERENT EVERY TIME THEY PLAY
IT.
THAT WAS THE BEST KILL EVER.
I'M GLAD YOU GOT TO SEE THAT.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> RECRUIT, ARE YOU DEAD?
IF NOT, GET ME DOWN!
THE CONTROLS ARE ON THE SECOND
FLOOR.
>> NOW YOU'LL NOTICE THAT DEQUAN
PICKED UP THE SHOTGUN THAT SHIV
DROPPED.
WE THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT MOMENT OF VICTORY SHOULD
HAVE A SUBSEQUENT REWARD AT THAT
MOMENT.
SO OF COURSE, YOU CAN PICK UP
GEAR RIGHT AWAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, DUDE.
DEQUAN HAS THE SAME AFFLICTION I
HAVE, YOU HAVE TO OPEN EVERY
SINGLE FRICKEN' CHEST.
THIS IS A DEMO.
ALL RIGHT.
IT IS SO TEMPT, THOSE GREEN
LIGHTS.
OH, CLAPTRAP IS NAGGING AT US
ALREADY.
IT IS NOT A BORDERLANDS GAME
UNLESS CLAPTRAP TRUMPS BETWEEN
NEEDY, BOSSY AND PATHETIC.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
IT, I STILL KIND OF LOVE
CLAPTRAP.
LET'S HELP HIM OUT.
THIS BORDERLANDS 3, YOU CAN
REVIVE MPC'S AND MPC'S CAN
REVIVE YOU!
LET'S HELP OUT CLAPTRAP.
>> FOCUS!
WOW!
I DID IT.
I SINGLE HANDILY TAKE ON THE CMV
AND SENT THEM PACKING.
ALL THAT IS LEFT IS SIGNAL
LILITH THAT THE MISSION IS
COMPLETE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> LILITH, I CAN SAFELY REPORT
THAT OPERATION IS A COMPLETE
SUCCESS.
I DID IT ALL BY MYSELF.
>> I'LL BET.
WELL, THE CULT HAS DESTROYED
EVERY OTHER CRIMSON RAIDER
STRONGHOLD.
THIS WILL HAVE TO DO FOR NOW.
SO WHAT'S YOUR NAME, KILLER?
>> I AM AMARA.
NICE TATTOO SIREN SISTER.
YOU MUST BE THE VOICE IN MY
HEAD.
>> YEAH, ABOUT THAT, NOT THE
WEIRDEST THING YOU WILL SEE ON
PANDORA.
BUT SERIOUSLY, THANKS FOR
ANSWERING HI CALL.
WE MIGHT NOT HAVE THE NUMBERS
BUT WITH A BAD [ EXPLETIVE ]
LIKE YOU, WE HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE.
WELCOME TO THE CRIMSON RAIDERS.
>> HEY, DO YOU HEAR BLOOD
THIRSTY SCREAMING?
>> MORE COV.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT, RECRUIT.
>> IT IS THE FIRE HAWK!
>> WATCH IT!
>> YOU'RE ON THE WRONG TEAM [
EXPLETIVE ].
>> SHE IS PRETTY RAD.
>> NICE FIGHTING, KILLER.
>> SO WE ARE GOING TO SKIP AHEAD
FOR A MINUTE.
I WANT YOU TO CONSIDER WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED SO FAR.
YOU ARE A NEW VAULT HUNTER AND
YOU JUST JOINED LILITH AND THE
CRIMSON RAIDERS.
OUR ENEMIES ON PANDORA ARE A
FANATICAL CULT CALLED THE
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
FROM HERE, YOU AND LILITH WILL
FIGHT SIDE BY SIDE TO CAPTURE
THE RECRUITING CENTER THAT
LILITH BELIEVES SHE CAN RECOVER
A KEY THAT WILL LEAD HER TO FIND
VAULTS ON OTHER WORLDS.
THE HUNT WILL EVENTUALLY LEAD US
HERE TO THE HOLY BROADCAST
CENTER WHERE A FEARSOME BANDIT
BOSS, MOUTHPIECE, BROADCAST
PROPAGANDA TO THE CHILDREN OF
THE VAULT ALL OVER PANDORA.
WHICH ARE HERE TO INVADE THE
HOLY RECRUIT MANY CENTER, FACE
MOUTHPIECE AND LIBERATE THE KEY
TO THE VAULT.
>> LIKE RANDY MENTIONED, WE
SKIPPED AHEAD IN THE STORY, IF
YOU NOTICE, WE SKIPPED AHEAD IN
LEVELS.I WANT TO TAKE THE TIME
TO SHOW YOU THE SKILLS IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
SO WHEN YOU FIRST GET YOUR
SKILLS IN BORDERLANDS 3, YOU
DON'T HAVE ONE ACTION SKILL
AVAILABLE TO YOU, YOU HAVE ALL
THREE ACTION SKILLS AVAILABLE TO
YOU AT THE MOMENT YOU OPEN IT
UP.
SO THEN, WHAT YOU DO, YOU QUIP
ONE OF YOUR ACTION SKILLS.
YOU WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ACTION SKILLS?
SO THIS FIRST ONE, IT IS
PHASEGRASS, WILL BE REMINISCENT
OF MAYA, CONTROL THE BATTLEFIELD
IN LIFTING ENEMIES UP TO THE
AIR.
THE NEXT ONE HERE IS PHASECAST.
AND PHASELAM, IT IS AN AREA OF
EFFECT THAT COMES OUT AROUND
AMARA AND DESTROYS ENEMIES AND
KNOCKS THEM BACK.
AS YOU PROGRESS, ONCE YOU PICK
YOUR ACTION SKILL AND QUIP IT,
ALSO OPEN UP AUGMENTATIONS THAT
ALLOW YOU TO FURTHER CUSTOMIZE
THAT ACTION SKILL.
MAXIMIZE THE SKILL OF YOUR
CHARACTER.
WE WORKED HARD THAT EACH OF THE
FOUR CHARACTERS ARE COMPLETELY
UNIQUE.
EVEN WITHIN EACH CHARACTER,
HUNDREDS OF MEANINGFUL OPTIONS.
IF TWO PEOPLE WANT TO TEAM UP
AND PLAY THE SAME CHARACTER,
VERY LIKELY HAVE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES.
>> YOU READY TO GO?
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> LEVEL UP.
ALL RIGHT.
LEVELED UP.
>> ONE THING TO LOOK OUT FOR,
LOOK AT THE DAMAGE NUMBERS THAT
COME UP OFF THE ENEMIES.
WE'LL USE SOME OF THE
INFORMATION LATER.
LOOK AT NUMBER, 56, 26.
>> 26 IS THERE.
>> OH.
>> NOW THAT IS A HIGH PERIOD
SHOTGUNS.
HIGH PERIOD SHOTGUNS HAVE
SHIELDS THAT COME OUT.
>> SWITCH BACK TO THE SHOTGUN.
[ MUSIC ]
>> IT IS A NEW ELEMENT TYPE,
RADIATION.
>> HIT CRITICAL MASS.
>> AT THE RADIATED ENEMY DIE, HE
WILL EXPLODE AND RADIATE THE
ENEMIES AROUND HIM.
>> OKAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT IS MAYHEM.
I THINK THAT HE CLEANED THIS
AREA UP.
LET'S SEE WHAT KIND OF LOOT WE
CAN FIND.
THAT IS AN OUTHOUSE BUT A GREEN
LIGHT.
SOME GOOD STUFF.
LET'S SEE HERE.
SO AMARA'S LEVEL 5, THESE
WEAPONS ARE LEVEL 5.
I WANT YOU TO NOTICE THAT,
NOTICE THE TWO HERE.
WE HAVE A RARE AND EPIC.
BOTH LEVEL 5.
AND THE REASON I WANT YOU TO
REMEMBER THAT, IS BECAUSE THAT
WAS KIND OF A CHALLENGING FIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED SOME HELP
FOR THE NEXT SECTION.
WE WILL BRING THIS A CO-OP
BUDDY.
CO-OP PLAYABLE, SPLIT SCREEN,
NETWORK, HOWEVER YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PLAY.
AMARA PICKED UP THE PURPLE.
LET'S TURNAROUND AND FIND OUR
CO-OP BUDDY.
THIS IS ZANE FLYNT.
THE OPERATIVE.
WE WILL SWITCH TO ZANE'S VIEW.
CAN WE FLIP THAT?
I WANT YOU TO NOTICE SOMETHING
HERE.
ZANE IS LEVEL 25.
OBVIOUSLY ZANE HAS BEEN PLAYING
LONGER THAN AMARA THAT IS LEVEL
5.
IF WE LOOK AT ZANE'S LOOT, HE
HAS HIS OWN INSTANCE OF LOOT.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
THIS IS CALLED LOOT INSTANCING,
IT IS A NEW OPTIONAL FEATURE IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT ALLOWS EACH COOPERATIVE
PLAYER TO HAVE THEIR OWN
INSTANCE OF LOOT.
INSTANCE LOOT IS HELPFUL FOR
PLAYERS THAT WANT TO PLAY
COOPERATIVELY BUT DON'T WANT TO
COMPETE FOR THE LOOT THAT DROPS.
NOTHING WORSE THAN GETTING ON
LEAN WITH RANDOMS AND A LOOT
NINJA IN THE GROUP, RIGHT?
INSTANCE LOOT SOLVES THAT
PROBLEM FOR PLAYERS THAT WANT TO
USE IT.
THE OTHER FEATURE THAT
COMPLEMENTS THIS IS LEVEL
BALANCING.
NOTICE HOW ZANE'S LOOT IS NOT
ONLY INSTANCED, BUT IT IS
ACTUALLY BALANCED FOR HIS LEVEL.
THAT MEANS THE LOOT, THE
ENEMIES, EVERYTHING
AUTOMATICALLY BALANCES TO THE
LEVEL OF THE PLAYER SO THAT
EVERYONE HAS A GOOD TIME.
AND MY COI DON'T KNOW GROUP,
SOME OF US WOULD GET AHEAD OF
THE OTHER, RIGHT?
THEN BACK TOGETHER, OUT OF
WHACK.
WITH INSTANCE LOOT AND THIS MODE
OF GAMEPLAY, EVERYTHING BALANCES
OUT.
>> NOW, THAT IS OKAY.
AND YOU CAN CLAP IF YOU WOULD
LIKE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
NOW THERE ARE STILL SOME OF US
WHO ACTUALLY LIKE COMPETING FOR
LOOT OR BRINGING IN OVERPOWERED
CHARACTERS TO HELP LEVEL UP THE
LOWER LEVEL CHARACTERS.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE LIKE THAT, WE
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THERE IS
STILL A MODE FOR YOU IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT IS CALLED CLASSIC MODE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
NOW THAT WE HAVE SEEN ZANE THE
OPERATIVE, LET'S HAVE A LOOK AT
WHAT HE CAN DO.
ZANE IS LEVEL 25.
WE EQUIPPED A LOT OF ACTION
SKILLS AND SKILL POINTS HERE.
YOU WANT TO WALK US THROUGH
THIS, PAUL IN.
>> LET'S DO THIS.
THE FIRST SKILL WE HAVE IS DING
DALE DIGICLONE.
IT WILL SHOOT GUNS AS WELL.
MY FAVORITE FEATURE, TELEPORT TO
DIGICLONE AND SWAP PLACES.
THIS IS DRONE THAT WILL THREE
OUT OR WEAKEN THE ENEMIES OR USE
GRENADES IF YOU HAVE GRENADE
MODE EQUIPPED.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE BARRIER
SKILL.
NOW ZANE WILL THROW OUT A
BARRIER IN FRONT OF IT AND BLOCK
INCOMING BULLETS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
ONE OF THE COOLEST FEATURE, IF
YOUR TEAM OR ZANE IS AROUND
THIS, CONFIRM BENEFITS LIKE
HEALING, EVEN IF YOU HIRE
THROUGH IT, ADD ELEMENTAL TYPES
TO THAT.
NOW PROBABLY MY FAVORITE FEATURE
OF ZANE IS THE FACT THAT ZANE
CAN USE TWO ACTION SKILLS AT ONE
TIME.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT ZANE, RIGHT?
HE HAS HIS BARRIER, WHICH IS
KIND OF LIKE THE SOLDIER CLASS'S
CAPABILITY.
HE HAS THE SENTINEL WHICH IS
LIKE MORDECAI BLOOD WING BUT
HYPED UP FROM THAT.
HE HAS THE DIGICLONE, LIKE OUR
SKILL FROM BORDERLANDS 2.
HE IS LIKE A SOLDIER, ASSASSIN
WRAPPED UP IN ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE AMARA, ZANE, WE KNOW
WHAT THEY CAN DO.
LET'S GET INTO THE HOLY
BROADCAST CENTER TO TO SEE IF WE
CAN FIND MOUTHPIECE.
>> OOPSY.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A TECHNICAL
ISSUE.
DON'T WORRY.
WE'LL POST THE WELCOME BID LATER
ALONG WITH SOME NEW, LET'S PLAY.
SIGNING OFF FOR NOW.
DON'T FORGET TO LIKE, FOLLOW AND
OBEY.
>> ANOTHER PERFECT LIVE STREAM
FROM OUR INFALLIBLE GOD QUEEN
TYREEN.
THE HOLY BROADCASTER OPENS ONCE
AGAIN TO HEAR YOUR SINS AND
RECEIVE YOUR SKINS!
>> OUCH!
>> TYREEN!
>> WHEW!
STILL GOT IT!
>> THESE ARE THE EMBARKING
TARGETS FOR THE SENTINEL.
ALSO CHECK OUT THE DAMAGE
NUMBERS, RIGHT?
HIS ENEMIES ARE LEVEL 27.
BUT HIS DAMAGE IS DOWN TO
AMARA'S GAME.
BECAUSE HE IS IN AMARA'S GAME
RIGHT NOW.
FOR AMARA, THOSE ENEMIES ARE
LEVEL 5.
ALL RIGHT.
WE CLEAN THIS AREA UP.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND SOME
LOOT.
OKAY.
NOW ONCE AGAIN, BEING HONEST,
YOU KNOW, TO SHOW THE BREAD OF
GUN, SOME OF THE BREAD.
WE CHEATED AND ADDED SOME CHESTS
WITH BETTER WEAPONS.
>> THAT RED CHEST WON'T BE IN
THE GAME YOU PLAY.
WE ADDED THAT FOR THIS PURPOSE.
IT IS OKAY.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF RED CHESTS.
YOU'LL BE FIND.
WE'LL FEED YOU BABY BERDS.
WE WANTED TO SHOW YOU SOME TEDO,
INSTEAD OF RELOADING, YOU THROW
THEM AWAY.
WHEN YOU THROW AWAY THEM IN
BORDERLANDS 3, SOME CRAZY [
EXPLETIVE ] CAN HAPPEN.
GUNS WITH LEGS.
LET'S SEE SOME OTHER OPTIONS.
WHAT DOES THIS ONE DO?
WE PICKED SOME DISTRICT OF [IND]
WEAPONS, AND GO INTO THE FIGHT.
>> WE AREN'T GOING TO LEARN.
KEEPING THOSE SPEAKERS.
>> OH, IT IS ADORABLE.
>> YOU CAN SEE THAT ONE MERV'S
ROCKETS OUT.
>> THROW A MERV GUN OUT.
CHECK THIS OUT.
CALMING ROCKETS.
THAT WAS A LITTLE CLOSE TO THE
EARS.
>> OH, GOODBYE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND YOU GUYS READY?
OH, YOU LEARNED!
WE CAN DODGE THAT.
>> THAT IS WICKED.
I SEE SOME AMMUNITION VENDING
MACHINES.
WALK UP TO THAT AMMO VENDING
MACHINE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THIS.
HE IS ALREADY FULL ON AMMO.
YOU JUST PRESS Y RIGHT THERE AND
RELOAD ALL OF THE AMMO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO IN AND BUY
THINGS ONE AT A TIME.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OF COURSE, YOU CAN BUY
INDIVIDUAL PIECES IF YOU WANT.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU GUY,
WHEN YOU PLAY A VIDEO GAME AND
HAPPEN UPON A ROOM WHERE THERE
IS AMMO AND VENDING MACHINES TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE STOCKED
UP, YOU ARE A SAFE BET THAT YOU
ARE ABOUT TO RUN INTO A BOSS
FIGHT.
NOT ONLY BORDERLANDS A A MUCH,
MUCH LARGER GAME THAN BEFORE IT,
MORE BOSS FIGHTS THAN EVER
BEFORE.
WE THINK BOSS FIGHTS ARE
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR PLAYERS
TO HAVE SKILL TESTED AND
REWARDED WITH KICK [ EXPLETIVE ]
LOOT.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND SEE IF WE CAN
FIND MOUTHPIECE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
[ MUSIC ]
>> YOU WILL DIE!
>> THIS SHIELDS LIKE AN
EQUALIZER.
ZANE USED HIS TELEPORT TO DODGE
THAT AREA OF EFFECT THAT
MOUTHPIECE JUST MADE.
OH [ EXPLETIVE ].
>> IS THAT ALL YOU GOT?
OH!
>> OH, GOD.
YOU NEED IT.
>> YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE LOOT,
MAN.
SOME LOOT OVER THERE.
>> GET THE LOOT.
>> DID YOU SEE THE GUN THAT
MOUTHPIECE WAS SHOOTING AT US
WITH SOUND WAVES FLYING OUT?
CHECK THIS OUT.
[APPLAUSE] ONE OF THE GREATEST
FEELINGS IN BORDERLANDS IS WHEN
AN ENEMY IS USING A GUN AGAINST
YOU, YOU KILL THAT GUY AND TAKE
THAT GUN AND USE IT AGAINST YOUR
NEXT ONE.
I LOVE THAT SO MUCH.
>> WELL, LET'S DO WHAT WE CAME
HERE FOR.
LET'S GET THE VAULT MAP.
>> AMARA WILL YOU PICK THAT UP?
>> HAVE YOU COME ALL THIS WAY
WITH THAT BUSTED [ EXPLETIVE ]
MAP?
OR SEE ME?
I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE A SUPER
FAN.
AND YOU MISSED THE SHOW.
WHAT IS UP WITH THE HUGS?
IT IS A THING I DO.
CHECK OUT THE SCREENS.
SO I OFFERED THE SONS MATCHES A
PLACE IN MY FAMILY BUT THEY JUST
WANTED GUNS AND CATCH.
THEY BETRAYED THE FAMILY.
THEN, SAID SOMETHING GREAT.
>> GODS DON'T NEGOTIATE.
>> GODS DON'T NEGOTIATE?
I LOVE IT!
LOVE IT!
LIKE I SAID, THAT MAP IS SUPER
BUSTED.
GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT.
I'LL SWING BY LATER TO PICK IT
UP.
YOU ARE MY MOST LOYAL FOLLOWER
VAULT.
AND YOU JUST DON'T KNOW IT YET.
>> SO YOU HAVE JUST MET TRY AND
TYREEN KAL CALYPSO.
THE CALYPSO TWINS.
WE LEARNED EARLIER ON PANDORA, A
CULT CALLED CHILDREN OF THE
VAULT.
EVERY CULT NEEDS LEADERS.
THIS VAULT IS LED BY THE KAL CAO
TWINS.
CULT OF PERSONALITY AROUND
THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW THE TYPE OF STREAMERS
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE KIND OF STREAMERS EVERYBODY
HATES.
THESE ARE THE DOUCHEY STREAMERS
OF THE IMPOSSIBLE FUTURE, THAT
YOU CAN POSSIBLY IMAGINE.
AS TYREEN IMAGINED, ABILITY TO
LEECH POWER FROM ANY LIVING
THING.
HER AIM TO USE THE CULT TO LEAD
HER TO THE VAULTS TO SOAK UP THE
POWER OF THE VAULT MONSTERS.
WE ARE VAULT HUNTERS.
WE CAN'T ALLOW HAD HER TO BEAT
US IN THE PRIZE.
WE ARE NOW IN A RACE TO FIND THE
VAULT HIDDEN IN OTHER WORLDS
THROUGHOUT THE GALAXY.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHEN WE GO TO
THE OTHER WORLDS WE ARE GOING TO
NEED A RIDE.
RIGHT?
SO LATER IN OUR VENTURE ON
PANDORA, WE WILL FIND A
SPACESHIP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE SANCTUARY.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT SANCTUARY 2.
SINCE SANCTUARY 3 IS OUR HOME
BASE IT IS A GREAT STOPPING
POINT BETWEEN MISSIONS.
ON SANCTUARY 3 WE MEET OUR
FRIEND, TRADE OUR LOOT AND
PREPARE OURSELVES FOR WHAT COMES
NEXT.
YOU'LL NOTICE HERE, THERE IS A
QUICK CHANGE STATION WHERE WE
CAN MODIFY OUR APPEARANCE.
BUT THERE IS A NEW VENDING
MACHINE HERE ON THE RIGHT.
THIS IS SORT OF A SPACE LOST AND
FOUND.
HAVE YOU GUYS EVER LOST LOOT IN
BORDERLANDS?
LIKE A PURPLE OR A LEGENDARY
LANDS, SOMEPLACE WE CAN'T REACH?
WE COLLECT ALL OF THAT LOST LOOT
FOR YOU, AND DELIVER IT HERE FOR
YOU.
YOU WILL NEVER LOSE LOOT AGAIN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS YOUR PLAYER QUARTERS.%
BECAUSE WE ARE PLAYING AMARA
RIGHT NOW, ALL OF THE DECORATION
AND EVERYTHING BILL AROUND
AMARA.
YOU CAN PLACE THINGS LIKE THIS
GUN, WE HAVE A TORRID PISTOL
HERE.
>> PRETTY RAD.
>> YOU CAN MODIFY THE PLAYER
QUARTERS HOW YOU WANT TO PLAY.
>> SINCE WE PICKED UP A PISTOL,
WE WILL TAKE IT WITH US ON A
TOUR AROUND SANCTUARY.
AND WHY DON'T WE STOP FIRST,
LET'S HEAD TO MARCUS, KEEP
GOING.
IGNORE THAT GOLDEN CHEST.
MARCUS'S PLACE IS RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER HERE.
>> OH, IT IS A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
FULL OF OPPORTUNITY.
>> NOW BORDERLANDS 3 MARCUS WILL
BE VENDOR FOR YOWP GRADES TO THE
-- UPGRADES TO STORAGE DECK
UNIT.
MORE STORAGE TO CARRY MORE LOOT
AND MORE AMMUNITION.
>> YOU WILL NOTICE THAT IT COST
CASH TO UPGRADE YOUR STORAGE.
>> MARCUS ALSO HAS A SHOOTING
RANGE BACK THERE, IF YOU WANT TO
GET YOUR SKILLS UP, PRACTICE
WITH ANY INTERESTING NEW GUNS
YOU FOUND, YOU CAN DO THAT.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON BOW HUNTER?
>> WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
AROUND THIS PLACE.
ISN'T THAT COOL?
THIS MAP CHANGED HANDS MORE THAN
ANY OTHER ONE.
TALENTED WORLD BUILDERS WANTED
TO GET THEIR HANDS ON THIS AND
MAKE IT GREAT.
IT IS NOT A PUB UNTIL YOU HAVE A
MOXXIE'S BAR, RIGHT?
[APPLAUSE]
>> THE NAME IS MOXXIE.
WHAT IS YOUR'S SUGAR?
THANKS FOR THE HELP SUGAR.
COME BACK.
>> LET'S TRY IT.
>> YEP.
ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT IS NOT GOOD.
>> NO.
>> BAD LUCK.
>> WELL, THANKS FOR ENCOURAGING
THAT.
>> LET'S KEEP GOING ON THE TOUR.
I LOVE SANCTUARY.
IT IS JUST SUCH A BEAUTIFUL, I
DON'T KNOW, THE LEVEL, I DIDN'T
WORK ON THIS ONE THAT MUCH, BUT
HELP GUIDE SOME OF IT.
BUT THE GUYS THAT DID THE ART
FOR THIS, ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
THESE ARE THE JOKES.
>> YOU'RE UP LATE.
>> GOOD EVENING!
KNOCK, KNOCK.
ANYONE HOME?
>> JUST A MOMENT.
ALMOST THERE.
OH!
WHEW!
SURPRISINGLY COMFORTABLE, YOU
KNOW.
LIKE SLUSHY SLEEPING BAG.
ALTHOUGH I FEEL A BIT VISCOUS.
>> SO TANNIS IS BACK.
LET'S GO HEAD UP TO THE BRIDGE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> HEY PAUL.
>> YES, RANDY?
>> WHAT CAN WE DO ON THE BRIDGE?
>> SO FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
WE CAN LEAVE THE PANDORA SYSTEM.
>> YOU CAN SEE PANDORA IN THERE,
IN THE DISTANCE.
>> WHAT'S UP, KILLER?
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET TO IT.
>> WE ARE IN ORBIT AROUND
PANDORA RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL CHECK IT OUT BRIEFLY
BEFORE WE TAKE OFF.
YOU CAN SEE THE DISTINCTIVE
MERIDIAN SCAR.
BUT WITH THE SPACESHIP LIKE
SANCTUARY 3, WE CAN VISIT OTHER
WORLDS.
NOW THIS IS EARLY IN THE GAME.
SO WE HAVEN'T UNLOCKED A LOT OF
THE OTHER PLACES THAT YOU WILL
GET TO EXPLORE.
BUT FOR NOW, WE ARE GOING TO DO
INTERSTELLAR FAST TRAVEL TO PROM
ETHEA.
>> I ARRIVED IN ONE PIECE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WE'LL GO DOWN TO PROMETHEA IN
A MOMENT AND MAKE OUR WAY TO THE
DOCKING BAY IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
IN BORDERLANDS YOU WILL BE ABLE
TO GO BACK AND FORTH FROM
PROMETHEA AND PANDORA AND ALL OF
THE OTHER WORLDS YOU DISCOVER
THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
>> MIGHT EVEN FIND A FEW
FAMILIAR FACES HERE.
>> WHAT'S UP BAD [ EXPLETIVE ]?
>> I LOVE MAYA'S LOOK.
SHE IS FULLY JEDI 'ED OUT.
WE'LL TAKE A COUPLE OTHER STOPS
ON THE WAY DOWN TO THE HANGER,
CONTINUE OUR TOUR OF SANCTUARY
3.
OH, YEAH, LET'S GO TO
HAMMERLOCKS.
>> HERE AT HAMMERLOCKS, ONE OF
THE COOL THINGS IS THAT
HAMMERLOCK ASKS YOU TO KILL
DIFFERENT CREATURES.
THIS IS A TROPHY ROOM FOR
KILLING THE CREATURES.
>> OH, IT IS YOU.
APOLOGIES, IT IS DARK AND I
NEVER ACTUALLY CLEANED THIS
MOLECULE.
>> YOU CAN SEE ALL OF THE TROPHY
MOUNTS ON THE WALL IS EMPTY.
WHICH MEANS WE HAVE WORK TO DO.
>> LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>> YOU ARE IN THE SHIP, YOU CAN
SEE THAT WE HAVE SHORT CUTS
BUILT IN.
>> THE MORE TIME YOU SPEND ON
PROMETHEA, THE MORE FAMILIAR YOU
WILL GET TO IT.
WE ENGINEERED SHORT CUTS AND
FIND YOUR WAY AROUND AND WHAT
YOU NEED PRETTY QUICKLY.
>> HOW IS YOUR DAY GOING?
>> HI THERE, SUGAR BOOTS.
>> ELLIE IS SHIP MECHANIC.
SHE RUNS THE CARGO BAY.
DOWN HERE, WE CAN CHECK OUT
VEHICLES WE COLLECTED.
WE CAN ALSO GET ACCESS TO THE
PLANETS WHEN WE ARE IN ORBIT.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME STOL AWAYS
THAT WE CAN MEET.
>> WHAT YOU WANT?
COME BACK, NEVER!
>> I THINK THAT VENDING MACHINE
THERE SAID VETERAN ON IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> DON'T LOOK AT ME LIKE THAT.
I'M DOING ALL OF THE REAL WORK
HERE.
>> AND HE LOCKED US OUT.
>> I THINK THAT HE IS BUILDING A
GIRLFRIEND.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT CLAPTRAP
IS LONELY.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HEAD TO THE
DROP POD HERE.
THIS WILL HELP US GET DOWN TO
PROMETHEA, IN FACT, WHY NOT SKIP
AHEAD A LITTLE BIT.
RATHER THAN START AT THE
BEGINNING OF PROMETHEA, WE CAN
JUMP FORWARD, A BUNCH OF LEVELS
AND I WANT TO SHOW YOU EXCITING
ACTION HERE.
IN THIS, PROMETHEA IS THE ATLAS
OF THE CORPORATION.
YOU WILL NOTICE THAT ATLAS IS
UNDER SIEGE BY MALLAWAN AND
PRIVATE ARMY.
IN BORDERLANDS, IN THIS
UNIVERSE, WHEN A CORPORATION
ATTEMPTS A HOSTILE TAKEOVER,
THEY DO IT WITH FULL MILITARY
GRADES FOR.
>> NOW BEFORE WE START, I WANT
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE GUN WE
ARE USING HERE.
THIS IS AN ATLAS PISTOL.
NOW THE COOL THING ABOUT AN
ATLAS PISTOL IS THAT IT HAS ALT
FIRE MODE THAT FIRES OUT A
TRACKING DART.
WHEN YOU FIRE THE TRACKING DART,
IT MARKS THE TARGET.
EVERY BULLET YOU FIRE
SUBSEQUENTLY WILL HIT THAT
TARGET.
LIKE THE FIFTH ELEMENT GUN.
>> FINALLY.
[APPLAUSE] SO LET ME INTRODUCE
OUR DEMOS, WE HAVE CHRIS PLAYING
AS ZANE.
ZANE IS CO-OP BUDDY THIS TIME.
PAUL IS PLAYING AS AMARA WHICH
IS WHAT IS ON SCREEN FOR US TO
WATCH.
YOU NOTICE AMARA AND ZANE ARE AT
LEVEL 10.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY SET THEM UP
WITH MICROPHONES SO THAT WE CAN
LISTEN IN ON CHATTER AS THEY
PLAY.
PAUL, CHRIS, YOU GUYS READY?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> HEY!
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S WATCH.
THIS IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
BORDERLANDS 3 CO-OP LIVE STREAM.
TAKE IT AWAY, PAUL AND CHRIS.
>> AFTER YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING IN.
A BUNCH OF ENEMIES OVER HERE.
I WILL HEAD ON THE RIGHT SIDE
AND TRY TO SPLIT THEM UP.
I SEE A COUPLE BEHIND THEM.
POP A TRACKER.
>> SWITCHING OVER.
>> NICE SHOT.
>> TAKING OFF SHIELD.
SWITCHING TO FIRE.
GROUND PLAN.
>> YES.
>> ONE ON THE LEFT.
WAR PACKER IS IN.
GRENADES ON THE CROWD, RAIN.
>> UP AND OVER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND YOU HAVE ONE THERE.
>> CAN YOU --
>> MISS MY DOOR.
HIT THEM WITH A GRENADE.
HE'S DOWN.
>> NICE.
>> THAT WEAPON DEPOT ISS A JUICY
TARGET.
THEY HAVE FORCE FIELD AROUND IT.
IF YOU SOMEHOW CRACK IT OPEN,
YOU WILL FIND SOME QUALITY FIRE
POWER IN THERE.
>> SO YOU HAVE JUST HEARD FROM
AURELIA.
WE PASSED HER INTRODUCTION AND
SKIPPED AHEAD.
TRUST YOU WILL BE ABLE TO MEET
AND SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH
AURELIA.
AS YOU EXPLORE PROMETHEA AND
OTHER AREAS IN BORDERLANDS 3.
AND YOU READY TO FINISH THE
FIGHT?
>> LET'S GO.
DO IT.
>> I'M GOING AROUND RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THROWING DOWN THE SHIELD.
>> COOL.
GOING TO SWING INTO THE SHIELD.
TAKING OUT SHIELD FOR YOU.
>> YEAH.
PICKING IT UP.
>> SWITCHING.
>> TRACKING.
>> PULL THEM ALL IN.
NICE.
WE HAVE A BIG CROWD ON THE LEFT
HERE.
>> SWITCH TO SHOTGUN.
>> FLASH SHOOTER.
GO FOR THE PACK.
>> I HAVE THIS GUY.
>> WE HAVE TWO MORE OVER THERE.
NICE.
LAST ONE.
HE'S DONE.
>> NICE.
>> A CHEST BACK HERE.
>> SEE WHAT YOU GET.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GOT A LEAD OFF PISTOLS.
>> IT IS LITTLE OP.
BUT YOU GUYS CAN SAVE IT.
>> DELAYED FIRE MODE.
THAT IS COOL.
>> READY TO MOVE ON?
>> ALL RIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WOW!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] THANK YOU,
GUYS.
WOW!
>> I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY GOT
THAT MATH JOKE, DIVIDE BY ZERO.
>> THEY GOT IT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
LOOK.
WE CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU GUYS TO
PLAY THIS MASSIVE GAME FOR
YOURSELVES AND DISCOVER WHAT-OTS
AND LOOT AND PLOT TWISTS AND
EVERYTHING THERE IS TO
EXPERIENCE AND EXPLORE IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
>> SO TODAY, BASED ON THE TIME
THAT WE HAVE, WE HAVE JUST BEEN
ABLE TO SHOW YOU A TINY FRACTION
OF THE GAME.
AND SO WITH THAT I THINK THAT
WHAT WE WANTED TO SHOW A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF THE BREATH WE HAVE.
WE PREPARED A TRAILER FOR YOU
HERE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[ MUSIC ]
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
WOW!
THANK YOU, GUYS.
OH, MAN.
>> OH, THANKS.
OH, WOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE HAVE EVER
SHOWN THIS MUCH OF A GEARBOX
GAME BEFORE, OR SOON AFTER
ANNOUNCING IT.
THE FACT IS, WE NEVER HAD THIS
MUCH TIME TO FINISH AND POLISH A
GEARBOX GAME BEFORE.
WE ARE FEELING REALLY GOOD ABOUT
THE POSITION WE ARE IN.
EXCITED TO BRING BORDERLANDS 3
TO THE WORLD.
AS YOU CAN PLAINLY SEE, WE HAVE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO WHAT
BORDERLANDS IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
WE MADE A COMMITMENT TO THE
STORY, THE STYLE AND THE DESIGN
THAT OUR FANS HAVE TOLD US LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT THEY CHERISH AND
WANT US TO PRESERVE IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
YOU KNOW, IT IS AN INTERESTING
TIME IN GAMES RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE,
MAKING ALL KINDS OF MONEY AND
INTERESTING STUFF OUT THERE.
WE JUST LOVE VIDEO GAMES.
WE THINK THAT VIDEO GAMES IS
SUPPOSED TO BE FUN.
WE LOVE BORDERLANDS.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE IS THAT
WE WERE TRUE TO WHAT IT IS.
AND IF YOU WANT TO PLAY
OFF-LINE, WE GOTCHA.
IF YOU WANT TO PLAY ON-LINE, OF
COURSE, ALL OF THE MODES ARE
THERE.
WE ARE GOING TO DO SOME KICK [
EXPLETIVE ] DLC AND ALL KINDS OF
FUN CUSTOMIZATIONS LIKE HEADS
AND SKINS.
NOT MICRO TRANSACTIONS, NOT ANY
OF THAT NONSENSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND IF YOU PLAYED A BORDERLANDS
GAME BEFORE, WE EXPECT YOU TO
FEEL RIGHT AT HOME.
BUT WE HAVE MADE SURE TO DESIGN
BORDERLANDS 3 IN THE STORY AND
GAMEPLAY AND EVERYTHING SUCH,
THAT THIS IS THE PERFECT ENTRY
POINT FOR ANY GAMER THAT IS
GOING TO BE EXPERIENCING
BORDERLANDS FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHEN BORDERLANDS 3 LAUNCHES ON
SEPTEMBER 13.
AND WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN TODAY SO
FAR, IT IS REALLY JUST
SCRATCHING THE SURFACE.
BORDERLANDS 3 IS MASSIVE.
IT IS BY FAR THE LARGEST
BORDERLANDS GAME THAT WE EVER
MADE.
WE JUST HAD AN HOUR TO TOUCH A
COUPLE THINGS NEAR THE BEGINNING
OF THE GAME.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
PUBLISHING PARTNER 2K GAMES, YOU
CAN EXPECT TO SEE MORE AND MORE
OF BORDERLANDS 3 THROUGH THE
SUMMER UP UNTIL THE LAUNCH ON
SEPTEMBER 1.
WE ARE PLANNING TO SHARE MORE
AND MORE OF THE GAME AT
UPCOMING SHOWS.
AT E3, GAMES CON IN GERMANY,
PENNY ARCADE EXPO, CRASH
GUARDIAN CON IN ORLANDO.
SO THAT SHOULD BE FUN.
AND WE ARE NOT EVEN FINISHED
TODAY.
IN THIS ROOM WITH US, WE HAVE
BROUGHT 200AMD POWERED MACHINES
WHERE YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO ALL
HAVE A CHANCE TO PLAY
BORDERLANDS 3 YOURSELVES.
IT IS GOING TO BE AN UNGUIDED
EXPERIENCE.
WE ARE GOING TO DROP YOU IN
PROMETHEA, DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
MAIN LINE QUEST, SIDE QUESTS,
JUST FREE PLAY, RIGHT?
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU 90
MINUTES.
I KNOW THAT ALL OF YOU GUYS ARE
STREAMING TO ALL OF YOUR
FOLLOWERS.
SO HAVE FUN.
WE WANT YOU TO HAVE A BLAST WITH
IT.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING THEM ON
TWITCH, IF YOU ARE WATCHING
THESE GUYS PLAY ON TWITCH, BE
SURE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
CUSTOM BORDERLANDS TWITCH
EXTENSION, IN GEARBOX.
LINK IT TO YOUR SHIFT ACCOUNT
AND START COLLECTING BORDERLANDS
3 LOOT TODAY.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE WAITING
FOR YOU WHEN THE GAME LAUNCHES
ON SEPTEMBER 13.
NOW IT IS GOING TO TAKE PAUL AND
THE REST OF THE GEARBOX GUYS A
FEW MINUTES TO GET EVERYBODY SET
UP ON THE DID STATIONS OVER
THERE.
SO PAUL IS GOING TO GET GOING ON
THAT.
AND I AM JUST, JUST SO GLAD THAT
WE ARE HERE TODAY.
THAT WE CAN DO THIS.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
BY THE WAY, WHILE THEY ARE
SETTING UP, FORTUNATELY, WE HAVE
THE FOLKS FOLKS FOLKS FROM KIND.
THEY SEEN BORDERLANDS 3 HERE
FIRST TIME AT THIS EVENT.
I WILL SAY GOODBYE FOR NOW AND
KICK IT OVER TO GREG, ANDREA AND
FRAN.
THEY ARE GOING TO SHARE THEIR
THOUGHT FORCE -- THOUGHTS FOR
BORDERLANDS 3.
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND BEING
WITH US.
I'LL SEE YOU SOON.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] CHEERS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN!
WE HAVE ALL SEEN BORDERLANDS 3,
I'M GREG.
THAT IS ANDREA, THAT IS FRAN.
AND ANDREA, WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> I AM SO EXCITED, GREG.
I MEAN, WE START OUT WITH
CLAPTRAP.
RIGHT?
THIS ICONIC CHARACTER, WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT IT IN THE
PRE-SHOW.
LOOKS AMAZING.
THEN WE HEAR ABOUT ALPHARA,
SLIDING, NEW WORLDS.
WHERE DO I START, GREG?
>> THERE IS, TOO MUCH TO START
WITH.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
FRAN, YOU ARE ON A LIMITED TIME.
YOU ARE GOING TO JUMP INTO THIS
THING.
REMEMBER, THREE HOURS OF LIVE
STREAMING OF BORDERLANDS 3 IS
ABOUT TO GO.
FRAN, WHAT DID YOU LOVE?
HATE?
TAKE AWAY INTEREST FROM IT?
>> I GO BACK TO WANTIN TO SEE
MORE PRODUCTION.
NUMBER ONE, MORE WORLD, BIGGER
GAME EVER MADE, I'M SEEING IT.
>> SANCTUARY 3.
>> YES, IT LOOKS SO COOL.
ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE I AM
THE KIND OF NERD THAT I AM, YOU
SEE THE ABILITY TREE, I WILL CAT
WAIT TO GET IN THERE.
SHOWING AUGMENT, SEEMS TO BE A
LOT IN THERE THAT MAKES IT
DIFFERENT THAN BORDERLANDS 2 IN
THAT REPORT.
THERE IS A LOT TO UNPACK.
I CAN'T WAIT TO STREAM.
>> AS WE SET UP THAT THREE HOURS
OF STREAM, PAUL SAGE IS GOING TO
COME OVER HERE.
ANDREA AND I WILL ASK A BUNCH OF
QUESTIONS.
OBVIOUSLY, WE HAVE THEM.
I NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THE SKILL
TREE.
PUTTING IN THE ACTION SKILLS AND
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT AUGMENTS
AND BUILDING OUT.
THAT IS WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
LOOTER SHOOTERS.
YOU WANT YOUR BUILD.
YOUR CHARACTER AS GOOD AS
POSSIBLE.
THAT SEEMS LIKE THAT IS WHAT
THEY ARE GOING FOR.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO WITH
THE VAULT HUNTER, CUSTOMIZE THE
SKILL TRADES THAT MAYBE TAKES
AWAY FROM THE ARGUMENT WHO GETS
TO PLAY WHO IN YOUR CO-OP GROUP.
I KNOW THAT I CERTAINLY RUN INTO
THAT IN PREVIOUS BORDERLANDS
GAMES.
NOW, MULTIPLE PEOPLE WANT TO
PLAY ZANE, DO THE DUAL YIELDING
SKILL, DIFFERENT BUILDOUTS AN A
WHOLE TEAM OF ZANE.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT YOU RUNNING
AS SIREN BEFORE HAND.
WASN'T FROM A DISTANCE TO SEE,
UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL.
HOW DID YOU FEEL?
YELL.
>> I'M NOT MAD.
I KIND OF HAD A HINT THAT A
FOCUSED CHARACTER.
WHAT IS INTERESTING TO ME, WHAT
I WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE SOME TIME
TO DIG INTO THE SKILL TREES
WHICH WE WILL DO ON WHAT GOOD
GAMES RIGHT AFTER WE ARE DONE
WITH THE POST-SHOW HERE.
SWITCH.TV/FM3.
>> I WILL GO TO THE SKILL TREE
AND CHECK IT OUT.
AND SEE WHAT AMARA THE SIREN HAS
TO OFFER.
>> JUST TO JUMP IN ON THAT, TALK
ABOUT FIGHTING OVER CHARACTERS.
THE LOOT INSTANCING THING.
>> GAME CHANGING.
>> DIFFERENT LEVELS.
WE TALK ABOUT ALL OF THE THINGS
ON TWITCH TWITCH.
FRAN, YOU NEED TO SET UP.
YOU AT HOME, NEED TO GET THE
ECHO CAST EXTENSION IF YOU GO TO
BORDERLANDS.COM AND LINK UP
TWITCH ACCOUNT.
GET IN THERE, START LEARNING AND
EARNING LOOT.
THEY WILL RUN INTO CERTAIN
CHESTS.
LOAD UP.
GET CERTAIN STUFF OUT OF THEM.
LOYALTY AND INSPECTING.
>> YOU ARE KICKING ME OFF.
>> YES.
EXACTLY.
ANDREA, YOU ARE STAYING HERE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THIS SAGE
FELLOW HAS TO SAY.
RIGHT NOW, MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT TWITCH EXTENSION I
KEEP TALKING ABOUT.
>> HELLO, TRAVELER.
CLAPTRAP HERE TO TELL YOU ALL
ABOUT THE BRAND NEW BORDERLANDS
3 TWITCH EXTENSION.
WE ARE GOING TO CHANGE THE
STREAMING GAME WITH THE POWER OF
ECHO CAST TECHNOLOGY THAT YOU
WON'T HAVE TO ASK STREAMERS TO
SHARE DETAILS ABOUT THE LOOT AND
SKILLS.
NOW DIRECT AND BACKPACK ANY
TIME.
LOOK AT THAT JUICY GEAR.
AND CHECK THIS OUT!
DRILL DOWN INTO EVERY SKILL TREE
AND SLAUGHTER ABILITY AND JUDGE
THE CRAP OUT OF THE STREAMER'S
BUILD.
EVEN THOUGH YOU WANT TO!
WE ALSO ARE BRINGING A NEW
LEVEL OF INTERACTTIVITY TO
TWITCH STREAMING WITH SPECIAL
EVENTS TO WIN END GAME LOOT BY
TUNING IN.
LINK YOUR SHIFT ACCOUNT TO
TWITCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
INTERACTIVE EVENTS LIKE THE RARE
CHEST EVENT FORCE THE POTENTIAL
TO WIN LOOT IN BORDERLANDS 3.
WINNERS ARE CHOSEN AT RANDOM
JUST LIKE IN REAL LIFE.
IF YOU ARE ONE OF THEM, YOUR
LUCKY HAUL WILL BE SENT DIRECTLY
TO END GAME MAILBOX.
BECAUSE EVERYONE NEEDS MORE
FREAKIN' LOOT.
THIS IS TANTALIZING TASTE FOR
WHAT IS TO COME FOR NEW TWITCH
EXTENSION.
LINK SHIFT AND TWITCH ACCOUNTS
TO BE READY FOR THE BIG REVEAL.
OFFICIAL BORDERLANDS EXTENSION
DEBUTS ON MAY 1.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THE ECHO CAST EXTENSION FOR
TWITCH IS A AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
BORDERLANDS.COM.
LINK EVERYTHING UP.
YOU CAN USE IT.
IN THE TWITCH CHAT, YOU ASK
QUESTIONS.
GO TO THE SPECIFIC STREAMS.
PEOPLE'S INDIVIDUAL LIVE STREAM.
GO TO TWITCH.TV.FM3 UNDERSCORE.
THAT IS WHERE YOU CAN GO TO GET
THE LOOT THAT WAY.
I DIGRESS, WE ARE JOINED AS I
LIVE AND BREATHE, BY PAUL SAGE.
HEY PAUL.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
HOW'S IT GOING?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING YOU?
THANKS FOR TAKING TIME TO TALK
TO US.
>> IT IS GREAT, AFTER WORKING ON
A GAME FOR FOUR YEARS AND SPEND
TIME WITH PEOPLE AND TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU LOVE DOING.
>> SO, WAS THIS THE BIG THING?
WAS THIS THE FINISH LINE?
OR NOW YOU LOOK AT WATCH AND I
HAVE TO GET BACK TO TEXAS AND
FINISH THE GAME?
>> YEAH, A PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT
OF THAT.
>> WHAT A MOMENT.
CHANGE THE MOMENT.
>> I WANT THE GAME NOW.
FASTER.
NOT ANY EXCUSES WHY IT WAS
DELAYED.
RIGHT?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> I GET ON IT.
NO SLEEP.
>> NO SLEEP.
NO, YOU ARE ALLOWED TO SLEEP.
WE LEARNED, WE HAVE TO TREAT ALL
OF THE DEVELOPERS BETTER.
BIG THING.
BY THE WAY, I TWEETED ABOUT IT.
LOVE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
EVERYBODY.
GREAT MOVE.
>> THE TEAM IS GREAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WISH WE
COULD DO, SHOW YOU ALL OF THE
TEAM BACK HOME IN FRISCO.
COMING BACK, WORKING HARD.
STILL WORKING AS WE SPEAK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS GAME
OUT IN A GREAT SHAPE.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, WE TOUCHED ON IT, RIGHT?
CRUNCH IS ALWAYS IN THIS
INDUSTRY BUZZ WORD.
NOT EVEN BUZZ WORD, HOT TOPIC.
BUZZ WORD PLAYS IT DOWN.
YOU GUY, RANDY WAS TALKING, YOU
NEVER HAD THIS MUCH TIME TO MAKE
A GAME.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO STAY AHEAD OF IT BECAUSE
OF THAT?
>> I THINK SO.
YEAH, I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, WE ALWAYS
WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE WANT TO
PUT EVERYTHING INTO THE GAME.
FOR US, OH, NO, DON'T MAKE ME
SACRIFICE THAT CHILD.
SOPHIE'S CHOICE SOMETIMES.
WE HAVE A PHILOSOPHY WHERE IT IS
LIKE, IF PEOPLE ARE EVER STAYING
LATE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
THEY ARE STAYING LATE, BECAUSE
IT IS A PASSION THING.
NOT ENFORCED THING.
YEAH, THIS TIME IT HAS BEEN
GREAT.
AND I HOPE IT SHOWS IN THE FINAL
PRODUCT.
>> I MEAN, THE FINAL PRODUCT
LOOKS AWESOME.
THAT IS THE BIG THING TAKING
AWAY.
WE HAVE, GOT TO WATCH THIS.
THE COLOR VIBRANT.
SKILL TREE SO FLUENT.
FOR YOU, WHAT IS THE CROWN JEWEL
OF WHAT WE SEEN IN BORDERLANDS 3
SO FAR?
WHAT IS THE THING, FOR
BORDERLANDS 3 IS ALL ABOUT?
>> WHAT FOR ME IS THE CROWN
JEWEL?
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I LIKE
THE MOST, EVEN THOUGH IT SEEMS
LIKE, OH, THIS ISN'T THE FLASHY
SKILLS IS THE WAY THAT WE
CONCENTRATED TO MAKE SURE THE
MOMENT TO MOMENT GUN PLAY FEELS
REALLY GOOD.
WE WORKED HARD ON THINGS LIKE
BULLET MAGNETISM.
THE AIM, WHEN YOU HAVE A
CONTROLLER IN YOUR HAND, DOES IT
FEEL GOOD?
DOES IT PLAYWRIGHT?
THEN WE ALSO HAVE OUR SKILLS
LIKE SLIDING AND MANTLING.
SO THE MOMENT TO MOMENT THING IS
A THING WE WORK ON SO HARD TO
GET RIGHT.
THAT IS KIND OF THE THING THAT I
AM REALLY PROUD OF.
HOW MUCH EFFORT WE PUT INTO
THAT.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THE
GUN PLAY.
FRAN AND I WERE WATCHING THE
DEMO, NOTICING THE GUNS, LIKE
THE SMG OR THE FASTER FIRING
GUNS, HAD LIKE NO KICK AT ALL.
LIKE LEVEL 3 GUNS.
>> YOU ARE LYING TO US.
WE KNOW THE BEGINNING OF
BORDERLANDS, THE KICKBACK.
>> YEAH, LIKE, ARE ALL OF THE
GUNS GOING TO BE THAT GOOD?
>> THAT GOOD?
I WILL SAY THAT THE TEAM HAD A
GOAL, RIGHT FROM THE OUTSET.
THAT GOAL WAS CAN WE TAKE GOOD
GUNS AND MAKE THEM AWESOME?
I THINK THAT LIKE, WHEN WE
STARTED THE SERIES, YOU KNOW, IT
WAS MORE OF A, LIKE YOU NEED A
FEW BAD GUNS TO FEEL THE GROWTH
IN THE PROGRESSION.
>> OF COURSE.
>> NOW, IT IS DIFFERENT.
LIKE CAN WE START GOOD AND JUST
MAKE THEM [ EXPLETIVE ] AWESOME.
CAN WE SAY THAT?
>> YOUR STREAM, MAN.
>> YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER THE [
EXPLETIVE ] YOU WANT.
THIS IS THE INTERNET.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SORRY, MOM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SO THEN, HOW DOES THAT PLAY
INTO THE NEW CHARACTERS?
RIGHT?
OF COURSE, I'M NOT NAMING NAMES.
I KNOW A LADY WITH RED HAIR.
SHE LOVES BEING A SIREN.
SHE SAW THAT YOU CHANGED HOW
SIRENS WORK.
NOT DISTANCE, UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL.
NOT THRILLED ABOUT IT.
COMING TO TERMS WITH IT.
DOES THE SKILL TREE ALLOW, WE'LL
SAY ANDREA, FOR EXAMPLE, LAY A
SIREN AS SHE WANTS TO?
>> AS AN EXAMPLE?
I HOPE SO.
YOU KNOW, IT IS IN THE NAME.
ACTION SKILL.
SO WHEN WE STARTED OUT, WE WERE
THINKING, MAN, WE SURE WANT
PEOPLE TO HAVE MULTIPLE ACTION
SKILLS VERSUS JUST ONE.
BECAUSE IT IS AN ACTION GAME.
RIGHT?
>> SURE.
>> WE ARE LIKE, OH, CAN WE DO
THAT?
THEN, WHAT MATTER IF YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT ACTION SKILLS?
PLAY STYLES.
HOW DO YOU USE THAT?
YOU CAN SEE THAT AMARA HAS THE
ABILITY TO GET UP CLOSE AND DO
HER, YOU KNOW, GROUND POUND.
ALSO CAN TAKE PEOPLE FROM FAR
AWAY, AND, YOU KNOW, HOLD THEM
THERE TO CONTROL THE
BATTLEFIELD.
THEN IF YOU WANT TO SIT BACK AND
CAST, WITH THEIR PHASECAST, YOU
CAN DO THAT.
THAT IS ABOUT WHAT THE PLAYER
WANTS.
ONE OF THE OTHER COOL THINGS IS
THE ABILITY TO MIX AND MATCH
THERE.
>> THAT WAS THE THING THAT I WAS
TRYING TO WRAP MY HEAD ABOUT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SKILL TREE,
ACTIVE SKILLS, SWITCH ANY TIME.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU GO TO THE SKILL TREE,
APPLY PASSES, APPLIES TO WHAT
SKILL I AM USING.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU HAVE OFF TO THE SIDE,
LITTLE DIAMONDS AND V'S THAT I
COULD APPLY TO THE ACTION SKILL
THAT I HAVE EQUIPPED OR ANY
ACTION SKILL?@>> ANYBODY ELSE C?
>> IT IS SO DEEP.
LOOK AT IT.
IT IS BEAUTIFUL.
IT IS A THING OF BEAUTY.
THIS IS WHAT I WANT OUT A
BORDERLANDS CHARACTER.
I'M GOING THROUGH MIXING AND
MATCHING TO MAKE MY ACTION SKILL
EVEN BETTER.
>> YEAH, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE
ARE GETTING THIS INFORMATION AT
ONCE, IT CAN SEEM OVERWHELMING.
AS YOU ARE GOING THROUGH AND
PLAYING, WE INTRODUCE OVERTIME
AND SLOWLY.
BECAUSE YOU ARE EQUIPPING AN
ACTION SKILL, THE THING THAT YOU
ARE SEEING THE LITTLE CHEVRON IS
WHAT WE CALL AUGMENT.
THAT AUGMENTS THE ACTION SKILL.
ALLOWS IT TO DO REALLY COOL
THINGS.
FOR INSTANCE, IF AMARA IS
HOLDING SOMEONE UP IN THE AIR,
YOU CAN SEE THE FIST POUND DOWN.
AND YOU CAN AUGMENT THAT.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE DIAMOND
THERE, THAT IS BASICALLY USES
THE ELEMENTAL TYPES.
STARTS OUT WITH ELECTRICITY.
SHE CAN TUNE ANY ONE OF HER
ACTION SKILLS TO USE ELEMENTAL
TYPE LIKE CORROSIVE OR FIRE.
SO AMARA IS VERSATILE AS FAR AS
ENVIRONMENTALIST.
>> THIS IS EXCITING.
>> EXACTLY.
THE FACT THAT YOU CAN NOW, IT
SEEMS, HAVE TWO SIRENS, THREE
SIRENS, FOUR SIRENS AND BUILD
THEM DIFFERENTLY IN YOUR GROUP.
IS THIS A MOVE, CLAPTRAP JUST
PASSED OUT BECAUSE SO EXCITING.
IS THIS A MOVE TO LET ME STAY
WITH MY CHARACTERS LONGER?
IN BORDERLANDS, THAT IS THE
THING YOU HAVE TO START DOING
OTHER BUILDS WITH OTHER
CHARACTERS TO BE READY TO GO.
THIS ONE, I'LL HAVE SO MANY
ACTION POINT, SKILL POINTS TO
GET ALL OF THE PASSES I WANT.
>> RIGHT.
IT ABSOLUTELY IS MOVE TO NOT
ONLY GET YOU TO PLAY LONGER BUT
AS YOU ARE PLAYING, IF YOU EVER
FEEL LIKE, OH, I MIGHT BE BORED
BY THIS, I WANT TO CHANGE SOME
THING, SLOTTING ALLOWS YOU TO
CHANGE THINGS SO EASILY AND
BUILD AND THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY
FORMULATE STRATEGY FOR ANY
SITUATION IN THE GAME.
SO IT IS FOR A LENGTH OF TIME.
IT IS, I MEAN, FOR PEOPLE WHO IN
MAX A LITTLE BIT, I'M NOT SAYING
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
>> OF COURSE NOT.
>> IF YOU DO, THE SYSTEM IS A
DREAM NOW.
>> THAT, IT IS SO DIVERSE.
I CAN'T WAIT TO DIVE MORE INTO
IT.
I HAVE TO ASK ABOUT THE LOOT
INSTANCING.
YOU GUYS FINALLY SHOWED IT OFF.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> SERIOUSLY, ALL OF US HERE WHO
WERE WATCHING THE PRESENTATION
WAS LIKE, YES!
THIS IS SO COOL.
>> RIGHT.
>> I STILL HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW IT ACTUALLY IS GOING TO
WORK.
>> OKAY.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO PEOPLE LIKE,
SO IN THE DEMO, LEVEL 5 AND 25.
YOU HAD DOES THAT WORK FOR
DAMAGE SCALING?
>> SO FOR DAMAGE SCALING, OUR
HOPE IS THAT IF YOU PLAY THIS
GAME, YOU WILL NEVER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THIS.
SINCE YOU ARE ASKING ME ABOUT
NUMBERS, WHAT I WOULD SAY,
IMAGINE THAT YOU COME IN AND YOU
ARE THE HOST OF THE GAME.
AND YOU'RE LEVEL 10.
FOR SOME REASON, I'M PLAYING
MORE AND I'M LEVEL 20.
I WANT TO JOIN YOUR GAME.
IF YOU AS A LEVEL 10 START
FIGHTING A LEVEL 15 ENEMY, YOU
KNOW, THAT IS SO TOUGH FOR YOU
AT THIS POINT.
BUT IF I COME INTO YOUR GAME AND
LEVEL 20, THEN IT WILL BE LIKE
I'M FIGHTING A LEVEL 25 ENEMY.
THAT IS, CORRELATIONAL
DIFFERENCE THAN WHAT YOU ARE
FIGHTING.
DON'T WORRY.
WE DO ALL OF THE MATH.
THE WHOLE GOAL IS THAT NO ONE
EVER HAS TO WOREY ABOUT IT.
YOU DROP IN AND THE GAMEPLAYS
FOR YOU.
>> IT IS FUN THAT YOU KEPT
CLASSIC MODE IN THERE AS A NOD
TO LONG TIME BORDERLANDS FANS
WHO MAY BE --
>> OR MONSTERS.
MONSTERS WITH RED HAIR WHO STEAL
LOOT FROM PEOPLE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M AN OPPORTUNIST, GREG.
>> GET THERE FIRST.
>> DON'T BE ON HER SIDE!
COME ON!
SO THIS WILL SOUND GOOFY, DO YOU
FEEL THE TEAM HAD MORE FUN WITH
THIS GAME MAKING IT?
YOU TALK MORE ABOUT MINI BOSSES.
SONIC DOOM BEING THE, IT FEELS
LIKE THE GAME IS GOING TO BE, IT
ALREADY IS OOZING WITH
PERSONALITY.
IT IS BORDERLANDS.
THEN THE ABILITY, LET'S HAVE
MORE CRAZY BOSSES.
NOW THE ABILITY TO INTERACT WITH
THE ENVIRONMENT.
WAIT UNTIL YOU GET TO TWITTER
TODAY, IT HAS BEEN AWESOME.
PEOPLE LIKE FREAKING OUT ABOUT
SOME OF THE DESTRUCTIBLE COVER.
TALKING ABOUT THE STUFF WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT, IN TERMS OF
LOOT.
IT SEEMS LIKE WATCHING IT, THE
FAN BASE SO EXCITED.
PUT IN SO MANY THINGS THEY
WANTED.
LAYERING IN WHAT YOU WANTED TOO.
>> I THINK, WITH BOSSES, YOU
TIPPED ON BOSSES, OR YOU
MENTIONED BOSSES.
BRIEFLY.
SO WHAT I WILL SAY, FOR ME, THAT
WAS A PASSION.
YOU KNOW, I, WE HAVE A GREAT
DESIGNER MATT COX THAT CAME IN,
YOU KNOW, HE WAS REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT BOSSES.
AND SO THERE IS A WHOLE TEAM
THAT IS LIKE, LET'S TAKE A
SUBSET OF OUR DEVELOPMENT TEAM
AND PUT THEM ON BOSSES.
SO YOU HAVE HEARD US SAY, NOT
VAULT, BUT WE HAVE SAID VAULTS.
VAULTS IN THE GAME.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT YOU SEE IN
VAULTS.
THAT IS WHERE WE GET SOME HUGE
BOSS LEVELS.
MINI BOSS, MOUTHPIECE THAT YOU
SAW THERE, WE HAD WEAPONS THAT
WERE A LITTLE BIT CHEATED UP.
IT MADE A EASIER TO DEMO THERE.
EVEN MOUTHPIECE IS A MINI BOSS
AT THIS POINT.
NOT EVEN A FULL BOSS.
>> THAT IS SO AWESOME.
>> I THINK THAT HE LOOKS REALLY
COOL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THESE WORLDS,
MAN.
WE ARE LEAVING THE PANDERUE
SYSTEM.
THIS IS A FIRST FOR THE
BORDERLANDS FRANCHISE TO GO TO
THIS MANY OTHER PLACES.
I MEAN, WHAT CAN WE, I MEAN, I
DON'T, I KIND OF WANT TO JUST
ASK, YOU HO MANY PLACES ARE WE
GOING TO?
I HAVE A FEELING YOU WON'T
ANSWER.
>> YOU COWARD.
>> OKAY.
I'LL TAKE THAT ON THE CHIN.
>> BUT LIKE, CLEARLY, THERE IS A
DIVERSITY IN LANDSCAPE THAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> IS THERE A COMMON THEME HERE?
SEE THINGS THAT ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE?
>> I HOPE WHAT YOU FEEL, LIKE,
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING, WE
DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE WHAT WE CALL
VISUAL BOREDOM.
THAT WAS ONE OF THOSE THINGS,
WHERE YOU CAN PLAY A GAME AND IF
YOU ARE IN THE SAME ENVIRONMENT
FOR THREE HOUR, FOUR HOUR, YOU
START TO FEEL A VISUAL BOREDOM.
WE WANTED TO PACE THINGS OUT.
YOUS A IN THE DEMO, PANDORA,
CLAPTRAP, THAT LOOKED DIFFERENT
FROM WHERE WE FOUND MOUTHPIECE.
THAT IS ON THE SAME PLANET.
ENVIRONMENTAL DIVERSITY IS HUGE
THING FOR US.
WE WANT EVERYBODY TO KNOW, YOU
ARE TRAVELING TO DIFFERENT
PLANETS BUT ALL OF THE GAMEPLAY
ON THOSE PLANETS.
THAT IS WHAT IS IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE OTHER THINGS CALLED
PLANETOIDS, YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN
A GLIMPSE OF A HUGE LASER THING.
THAT IS ASTEROID.
THAT HAS LOW GRAV ENVIRONMENT ON
IT.
THERE ARE PLACES TO GO THAT IS
COOL AND DIVERSE IN THE GAME.
>> PRESEQUEL MOVEMENT IN THAT.
>> LOW GRAB IN THAT.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, IF YOU
LOVE ENVIRONMENTAL DIVERSITY,
YOU SHOULD PRE-ORDER BORDERLANDS
3 TODAY!
SEPTEMBER 13 IS RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER.
DELUXE, COSMIC, BOOST, AND THE
PRICE GOES UP IN SEPTEMBER.
PRE-ORDER TODAY.
Mr. SAGE, WHAT IS NEXT FOR
YOU?
THIS IS NOT THE LAST STOP FOR
BORDERLANDS 3 ON THE WORLD TOUR.
>> IT IS NOT.
LIKE WE ARE GOING TO BE SHOWING
UP AT ALL SORTS OF PLACES OVER
THE SUMMER.
RIGHT?
WE ARE GOING TO BE AT E3.
AND YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN RANDY
MENTION THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE AT PENNY
ARCADE EXPO.
>> RIGHT.
>> WE MIGHT MAKE A STOP IN
EUROPE AT GAMES COM.
I AM PERSONALLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO THAT ONE.
THAT WILL BE AWESOME.
>> THEN ANOTHER PLACE TO VISIT.
>> GUARDIAN CON.
>> IT SUPPORTS CHARITABLE
CAUSES, PLAY BORDERLANDS THERE.
WHAT A COOL MOVE?
WHY GUARDIAN CON?
>> YOU KNOW, THOSE GUYS ARE
AWESOME, RIGHT?
>> THEY REALLY ARE.
I BELIEVE THERE IS A CHARITABLE
PART OF THAT.
THAT IS FASCINATING AND THAT IS
REALLY COOL.
KUDOS TO THOSE GUYS.
WE ARE LOOKING REALLY FORWARD TO
BEING THERE.
>> THAT IS GOING TO BE JULY 5-6
AT THE ORLANDO, FLORIDA.
GET TICKETS AT GUARDIANCON.CO.
PAUL.
ANY FINAL THOUGHTS FOR PEOPLE
WATCHING?
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO LEAVE THEM
WITH?
>> ANY FINAL THOUGHTS?
LOOK, YOU KNOW, THANK EVERYONE
FOR TUNING IN, MAN.
THIS IS GREAT.
IT HAS BEEN SO LONG THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME OUT
HERE AND SHOW IT OFF IS HUGE FOR
THE TEAM.
TO THE TEAM BACK HOME, KEEP
WORKING, GUYS.
HOPEFULLY WE --
>> TURN OFF THE STREAM.
>> HOPEFULLY WE DID THIS WELL,
MAN.
THANKS AGAIN FOR HAVING US.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE FUN
IS FAR FROM OVER.
OF COURSE, FOR THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE, FIND ALL BORDERLANDS STUFF
ON TWITCH, YOUTUBE, SOCIAL MEDIA
AROUND THE GLOBE.
RIGHT NOW, THOUGH, YOU HAVE
THREE HOURS OF BORDERLANDS' LIVE
STREAMING COMING TO YOU.
ALL BORDERLANDS 3.
ALL OF THE STREAMERS YOU KNOW
AND LOVE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ANDREA, YOU ARE RUNNING OVER
TWITCH.TV.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, RIGHT NOW,
WE ARE GOING TO THROW OFFICIALLY
TO PROFESSOR BROMAN.
THANK YOU ALL FOR WATCHING.